it was door die time in the semi-finals
of parts chess champion showdown for if
the best chess players on the planet
were back to do battle for the two
coveted spots in the finals world
champion Magnus Carlsen sealed the deal
against Levon Aronian while Fabiano
Caruana staged an epic comeback against
Wesley so to book his ticket to the
championship round
it's Magnus versus Fabi number one
versus number two day 7 of exciting
action coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to the
clutch chess finals I'm Jennifer Sahadi
and I'm here with Grandmaster dancers
are went and Maurice Ashley for a
thrilling finale he has welcome well
thank you Jennifer hello Maurice and
hello everyone thank you for joining us
for this first day of the finals
knockout match of clutch chess world
champion Magnus Carlsen was chill he was
smooth he did the Magnus thing and he
was a dominant player in the semies but
the way fabbi got there was something
special on a completely different note
he did it with an epic comeback and I'm
just amazed we've got the finals we were
looking forward to a rematch of the 2018
World Championship match of 12 games
this should be a lot of fun Maurice
indeed what more could you ask for
I mean it's number one in the world
versus number two in the world and not
by close margin either they're only
they're the only 228 hundreds on the
planet and as you said they played a
world championship match against each
other it was drawn after 12 games
Magnus one in the the tiebreaker which
was rapid chess but lately fabi's been
showing it and that match coming back
against Wesley was really one that was
special and let's take a look at how
they got here it couldn't have been more
different it's actually as different as
their playing styles Magnus Carlsen
really dominated the entire match he
started the final day of the semis with
back-to-back victories and then posted
to the win actually clinched before the
final game Fabiano by contrast actually
had a terrible day one and he just
pummeled Wesley so yesterday as three
victories in the regular games and then
that crucial clubs victory leapfrogging
over Wesley so take the epic comeback
a fantastic comeback for sure one for
the ages no doubts about it and welcome
to the finals to our finalists and what
is our format and schedule going forward
we've got two days so your weekend will
be filled with these thrilling games
between Fabiano and Magnus today we're
gonna play six games and then tomorrow
we're gonna do the same thing with those
intensifying clutch games we've got a
time control of game time with a five
second urban command for those of you
who are just joining us hey welcome to
the party it's great to see our New York
ship grow as the days go by as welcome
everyone this time can try love it
because it can create masterpieces but
it can also create absolute blunders and
I think we're gonna get a little bit of
both today no question about it thrills
and spills and Maurice drill down a
little deeper on these two Titans and
how do they match up well absolutely no
complaints that we have these two
wonderful players in the event where
they got here without certainly
different paths Magnus had to take care
of the young upstart in Geoffrey Jean
who did win a clutch game but Magnus at
the end said listen I'm the boss and
then he proved it once again against
Levon Aronian we didn't expect that
match to be that different that kind of
different score as Magnus really
pummeled poor LaVon Bobby on the other
hand had a solid match against Lanier
but it was this razor-sharp on the edge
almost on the edge of the cliff was Cara
Juana and had to come back against
Wesley so in order to book his ticket to
the finals and it's now the two of them
well we know fabulous Bobby can indeed
get it done you see him ranked only 11th
in the world but lately his rapid play
has been superb we've seen him play very
well at this time control he remains the
number two in the world of course a
classical chest losing that match in
2018 as we said but it's all about his
sterling play his incredible preparation
we've seen him drop novelties and new
ideas even braggadocious ideas like that
check on h4 that he allowed Wesley
sacrifice
rook early in one of their games Bobby
comes with these kind of poisonous
innovations that you have to be prepared
for when he's got you in his clutches
forget about it his technique can be
ruthless technical precise that is what
Magnus knows he has to watch out for as
this young man has defeated him many
times before but Magnus has told us you
know what playing against anyone I'm
optimistic and why not when you have the
number one ranking in the world no.1
rapid ranking in the world you're the
current world champion you've been champ
from 2013 you're the boss you're the big
dog they have to come get you and Magnus
defeated Khurana as he tried to unseat
him in 2018 but he continues to show
does Magnus the Norwegian superstar that
he's just simply unparalleled he is
chasing not to be the best in the world
but being the best of all time and his
record has shown it he has one classical
events he is one blitz events here's one
rapid events what hasn't he won it's a
question of piling up the numbers every
event he put who wants to destroy his
opponents by showing his best chess and
speaking of which against Fabi head to
head his best chess has been pretty good
in rapid exhibitions nineteen nine
that's a spanking folks that does not
look good for Fabi fans but as I said
Bobbie is looking to somehow shed those
ghosts of the past and finally take down
this incredible champion we'll see if he
can get it done in question and well
thank you for that Maurice Jennifer it's
always prestigious when we have a number
one versus number two in any sport and
you know a lot of honour at stake but
tell us about the business end of things
well it is a largest prize funded online
chess history that's right 265 thousand
dollars or up for grabs
including a phat 50k for first place
there's also all that clutch money
Maurice how big did the pot get well it
be getting bigger and bigger and we've
got a nice chunk of change in front of
us because of those draws in game 12 in
three of those game twelves in the
quarterfinals two of the one in the
quarterfinals in both of the semis in
fact we've got an extra chunk of change
that showed up in bonus money that is
landed on games eleven and twelve twenty
thousand to be precise so since that
money is split instead of those games
eleven and twelve be worth the
traditional three thousand they are now
worth 13 thousand
add that up that's 26 thousand extra
plus the four thousand from games five
and six that will be played today that's
four more that's thirty thousand in
bonus money alone somebody's gonna walk
out of this match with fifty thousand
dollars and maybe extra change
Cucina can you say it's nice to be a
chess player of these days it certainly
is I remember my US Championships I
think six thousand for first two
quarters was what we were all fighting
for so times they are a-changin changing
for the better and I'm being asked to
make predictions well what do you say
Jennifer I'm sorry I am a huge fan piano
carol fan and I'm hoping that it's close
and that he even wins but I gotta go
with magus predictions wise because it's
it's madness Bobby is so precise so good
at the openings but in game 10 I'm just
worried about those last two minutes yes
that Magnus is gonna be sharper in the
last two minutes and I don't know if I
can honestly say I go for anyone but
Magnus here well I mean you're certainly
going with a favor no doubt about it
Magnus Eason is the world blitz champion
he's a real rapper Jimmy if the world
champion so you're making a good thing
but you know that come back yesterday if
you're not feeling it after something
like that I don't know what to say
I gotta have to go with Bobby it's just
he did yesterday just was so stunning a
down six to two after day one come on
it wasn't remarkable come back and I
want to go with him yes I love your I
love your American optimism I love it
but you know I go back to that game that
he played against Wensley those final
two minutes where it just went back and
forth and back and forth and I'm just
I'm just afraid that Magnus would have
turned that game around you know what I
mean like you break the tie break the
tie well I'm gonna have to agree with my
elder indeed he's a wise man of course
of course of course and I'm saying all
that tongue-in-cheek
the reality is Magnus is the favorite
that's clear that's no question about it
but I'm gonna go with Bobby I'm just
gonna throw out a Fabi come back again I
think it's gonna be Fabiana I think it's
gonna be in a comeback again going with
the underdog to be sure we'll see if he
can pull it off and the games have begun
and it looks like var has gone with
Magnus var we have in the truck has gone
with Magnus and we got 50/50 on the
panel two of us would be right and two
of us will be wrong there are no tied
matches here oh no and we have a game
similar to yesterday guys although I
believe there was a dc-3 anyway the pawn
on e4 was taboo because there would have
been a queen g4 I'm for King g7 and e4
so um what do you make of this yes you
must like this right yeah and so does
Magnus assisted as this whole line has
been in his repertoire for some time it
matches up it's kind of an echo of this
fashion of cuff systems that he was
playing as black in that World
Championship match in London and 2018
the ideas from whites point of view is
he's got well it's kind of hard to say
that he's got central control because
black can always play for six c6 d 5 but
what Magnus is trying to do is create a
flexible situation in the center is
going to make a development like with
his Knight coming to f2 is Bishop coming
to g2 and he's Castle
yeah look more you play the game with
the two bishops
all right no you're not looking at the
updated board because I saw you're
looking at your analysis but now check
out what happened whoa
the Fred King f2 that was what we used
to call this in Seattle we wouldn't play
odds games with each other but we would
play 1 F 2 F 3 is white followed by King
F 2 followed by G 3 in King G 2 so we
lose a lot of time we spot our opponent
something and if we called it the friend
King F 2 okay
do not do this at home anybody and it
looks absurd the finals
let's can you say that yes I mean I just
want to put it out there it looks absurd
right it looks how dare you develop your
king to f2 it looks like he wanted to
maybe move another piece and but it's it
couldn't even be a mouse slip because
it's hard to go King f2 if you meant to
play Bishop somewhere else or or the
Queen somewhere you wouldn't get to f2
that uh that's a way off and then to
compound it if you did blunder king f2
to a mouse slip you wouldn't play D to
d4 to open up the game or give your
opponent a chance to open up the game
the next on the very next move you say
oh no what did I do and then you say let
me fix all this i Headley gave my king
to g2
this is wild and now Magnus is actually
stopping to think after the very natural
d5 Wow predictions right now this is
this is making you want to sign up for
this line guys I have played some
variations of this before trying to make
the English into a basically like an
Enzo Indian but it's this activity for
black yes it's very attractive but does
it look better than it is it looks great
I mean it looks good enough to my eyes
obviously this king is terrible on f2
and we're absolutely sure that white
somewhere in the very near future is
going to be playing King g2 so that's
another tempo and blacks pieces knight
c6 and taking on e4 playing are you know
suggesting themselves I don't know what
to say I I'm having this imaginary
conversation with myself it goes like
this
Magnus has Peter Jaime as his chess
coach his trainer and Peter come you
know wakes Magnus up in the morning and
says I've got this great idea Magnus I
need you to play King f2 or let's
reverse it Magnus says to Peter I've got
this great idea to play king of two in
the finals tomorrow and beaters like I
will strangle you that's what that's
what I saw it yes I oughta bleah gasp
while you were talking and I wanted to
just jump in you were talking and
extolling the virtues of development to
the bishop at age 3 and all that right
and I was like yes sir please bail us
out what's going on with P f2 and then
d4 I mean I'm glad to know that you have
the same reaction as well but what's
interesting about this position though
is Bobby played d4 and I got to tell you
with a king on f2 you would have I
wouldn't have cared if I lost upon you
you could have my d5 pawn
I'd have been looking for sacrifices
somehow potshots at the king I would
never have shut the position down and
played d4 just to get this passed pawn
because I get the feeling like I'm just
blocking up the position in black and
whites favor looks very snug on this
square like what about Queen b6 check in
Queen B - well Queen b6 instead of d4
right something like this would have
made more sense to me and then going can
you you can't play Queen d2 because then
I trade Queens and I take on e4 right
and exactly everyone's happy then I mean
yeah actually something like that looks
like it would make more sense to take
advantage of this position although
maybe you have bishop deport in between
move not too gay
I mean Bishop sees not to get too much
into the weeds but I'm just saying like
Queen due to Queen due to a bishop due
to pawn takes e4 Bishop c3 does white
hang on there maybe but it's certainly
in blacks favor I'm happy to play after
Queen B to take sorry saying Queen d2
right now I can play Queen d2 eirick
hangs yeah so I can't even trade Queen
although in this line no Bishop d4 was
playable there but it looks so
convoluted
what do you mean is the convoluted King
what move them word that move seven yes
so the black still had so I mean white
still had some ideas even against that
but it is sad to see that pawn blocking
the potential attacks of the King an f2
I have to totally agree with Marius you
you almost want to wipe it off the board
exactly you know you you're kind of
thinking about peace sacrifices and you
know keeping things wide open you're
almost like looking at stuff like this
yeah that's what I'm talking about
that's the yeah Sarah wonhui no I mean
oh it's right I'm hard to believe
because the Kings in a very strange way
ultimately we'll probably be safe on g2
sort of in the meanwhile I mean you
wanna in a slash and burn and do
something a little bit more extravagant
let's say all right after D 492 we have
the feeling that 99 f4 is a really nice
move because it's it's it's looking to
blockade the position on d3 and again
one of the things that I'm really
finding at the very highest levels is
that the top players are having a hard
time getting
play against one another positions where
you know like
it's not about preparation Magnus has
achieved that it's it's truly remarkable
and after Knight f4 let's just catch up
with the players okay
so fab e's looking to maybe play 95 + d3
if he can get the chance and no we're
not coming back to blockade we're coming
back to plant on a very rooted beautiful
square in the set of the board d5 drop
back okay he has just respected Magnus's
play almost completely in this this way
you know magnus didn't just wake up fall
out of bed and drop king f2 on the board
you know that yeah so you know for a
fact that he had this prepared it's we
we just have to say for us it's a
remarkable move to see on a chess board
that you move your king or to this
square that early without developing
your pieces now he's achieved the
position where that king may look a
little off on f2 but you're not getting
at it you're not hitting it in any way
and it only takes him a couple of moves
now to move his rook to the e-file and
then bring his king over and then his
other work to the b-line and you're
starting to like white's game more and
more and more relaxed only real break is
f5 like as a true break but it looks
like it's under control I think I said
it and he did it I said it was under
control at the moment and Bobby said I'm
playing it thank you very much it's on
the board I've got to do it let's go and
now he's taking on e4 he could have
played it before by the way before he
played rook back to e8 he could have
played it immediately
I played rookie eight I'm sorry I saw
are you sure he did play with me no he
broke e8 in the game he played rook e8
in the put his knight on e5 so at the
moment when he played that back when he
played that move rook e8 on move
fourteen he could have played f5 right
then you always look for breaks you
always look for a palm break pawn bury
pawn break prom break right now he could
have executed right
in that position with f5 instead of
bringing his rook back first he brought
his rook back then brought his Knight
out then the second time his room ended
up on e5 then he executed what is the
thematic break black should be playing
for cuz man look the guy's King looks a
little suspect somebody's got to go
knocking on the door and the way you do
it is to break with pawns you're not
gonna just sack all your pieces to get
there so you've got to look to see if
you can break open pause this was a very
interesting play and it is finally
frozen Magnus for a bit although Magnus
has been playing very slowly guys he's
under five minutes already Fabi with
seven level Wow for somebody who brought
such as remarkable surprises King f2 to
the table I wouldn't have expected that
it's it's Magnus who's down on the clock
I just wanted to say that before the
move fi I was really getting myself all
excited for Magnus is position it to
play the move f4 followed by e5 and
Queen h5 so I sum up a move f5 is not
necessarily ooh I gotta go after White
King but more like ooh I better stop f4
and f5 and get in my break now if white
gets f4 and f5 it's very unlikely that
I'm going to be played be playing at 6
so I saw it as a kind of a defensive
approach a good approach nonetheless and
after takes on e4 this is where Magnus
is having a long think and I'm really
not too sure why for me Bishop takes e4
is more or less of an automatic because
I'm thinking you know get your pieces
out right and if I always want to get my
pieces out with a gain of tempo so if I
could take with the bishop and then
follow it up with Queen d3 I'm seeing a
tempo over here so for me Bishop takes
e4 is automatic maybe rook takes e4 yeah
what would they be the benefit of work
takes over Bishop takes it maybe there
were kind of if I was kind of active so
potentially after Bishop b4 there could
sometimes be Rick h5 tempo but he didn't
you agree with you yes and he took with
the bishop and remarkably he took that
long he's
nine only and seven oh one left on the
clock and father instantly played bishop
at five trades on the board Magnus does
get a five-second increment but it took
him a lot of time to evaluate that this
would be the way he wants to play we do
have a very interesting position as that
King is not going to be in any trouble
anymore the King gonna have to can go
yeah and it's not going to have any
problems many trades right I mean the
night there's too many trees in the
position Maurice and you were saying the
knight on d5 is 95 is superior to its
black counterpart but but the truth is
having lost that pawn on e4 that Knight
is not as stable as it used to be so it
can be challenged later a 97 for example
not now obviously because the rook is
sitting on the e-file but sooner or
later that night can be challenged I
don't think he's gonna play an exchange
sack although that's in the works as
well a rook takes on d5 if necessary but
this kind of position now Fabi can play
Queen d7 double rooks on the f5 and look
to play chess look for his chances the
biggest thing for him is to say I got
out of this novelty I don't think the
opening novelties matter by the way in
matches like this I really don't I think
it's about play I got out of it fine and
I'm ahead almost 5 minutes on the clock
that's very meaningful in those types of
time control it's very meaningful Magnus
is playing like it's a classical game
guys right now having said all of that I
still use in the weirdest way I
understand that black is gonna play
Queen d7 and rook cafe well then I mean
great you I will play f4 that's my
majority speaking for itself he blames
the rooks are going to be doubled on the
F file for black but I'm gonna shut down
the F file with the move f4 let's say
Queen D let's just put some moves on the
board Queen d7 King G - let's just put
another move on the board work f8 and
I'm not saying that this is the best
over anything like that just just to try
to get a flavor of the position now here
I actually have a problem I'm not 100%
sure where my Queen should go or whether
my rook should lead my queen something
like rookie foreign Queen e2 or
I don't know Queen B 3 um by the way I
should point out yes sir yes that Magnus
is currently down still 2 minutes and 9
seconds left
rook f5 Queen Queen d7 did happen and he
did double rooks on the F line Magnus
played rook b1 and rook e1 remember
chess is so much about breaks I see two
breaks for black and that is b5 + g5 now
g5 ooh
that's opening up all kinds of issues on
your king but the b5 break on the other
hand had to be stopped because b5 was
gonna happen and the knight on d5 was
gonna have his legs kicked from under it
so Magnus was really smart and playing
this move work to be one you said listen
I'm gonna make sure that move can't
happen because my knight needs some kind
of security and also let me get my King
to a safe spot so he's got both Bobby
just played rook from F back to f7 and
worked to b2 by magnets magnets down
under two minutes now and for me again
that knight on d5 is annoying but I
can't play the 97 I want to play because
of the deep on d4 pawn so if your Queen
leaves just give me a break so I can
play this move I think we're gonna see
b6 and eventually Knight to e7 thought
you know he's gonna try to figure when
your queen leaves that's what I want to
do in the meantime I think the rooks
might want to double on the e line
although bluffing incomes that comes
into mind well the story for me is I
feel that this is a clear advantage
white but the the issue is the clock
management or in this case mismanagement
of the clock by Magnus well that come
back to Honda I mean from from White's
point of view he wants to use his Queen
King side majority from and that means
like literally leverage it to an attack
about showing how he's going to do that
in just a second black has this past
pawn in the center going anywhere so to
my way of thinking if I'm white you're
right Maurice b5 could you know really
impact my knight stability so you know
you mentioned the rook be
I was thinking if you're really worried
about b5 just stop it with a four and
play real k2 rookie - in any case for me
what I'm thinking is white should play
the move eight for he should flavor look
e - and he should play rookie six okay
why don't you get those three moves in
you can really get a feeling like white
is beginning to take more and more
territories he's making advances now I
just like to hear from you're both like
where do you see blacks active play
coming should he play g5 as you
mentioned oh you know I don't like the
break g5 I think you're right he does
right now black has to be very careful
mindful especially of that doubling of
rooks so okay before I could say
anything he played rook to e8 and said
let's get rid of a pair of these rooks
challenge these pieces and at least you
don't see a hook like you planted on e6
that was just too good so that's on the
board he did double rooks and very
natural move time to get rid of a pair
it looks like he could also reconnect
with rook back to f8 as well just so
that he's ready again for later but
certainly white white is another choice
a4 did happen as you mentioned why it is
somehow hanging on by a thread
I wished if I were black I could find if
I were right I would love to be able to
play a move like a f5 so like a player
q6 thinking that tactically you can't
take an F I it because overtakes you
Ajax but it seems like f5 could be met
first by taking on Amy - and then taking
on f5 so that idea doesn't work so let's
flip it around like how do you increase
your advantage here is Wyatt exactly but
you your ideas correct Jen I mean it's
the principle in the position of you as
white wanting to leverage your majority
your majority is the king sigh mmm
you're the proud possessor so you start
thinking how do I play f5 and maybe that
means you play g4 but you start thinking
how do I
build an attack now only the side of the
board you know black sitting there
saying well the Queen site is fine a 77
spine on a d4 you know I own it
but where is my you know counterplay
yeah look he's just by sorry Queen f7 so
he wrong attitude as far as I'm
concerned at the moment unless you play
g4 you want to play g4 play g4 and give
us something to look at
if you don't play g4 it's time to play
the time on the on the clocks that you
have when you play blitz or rapid you
play the time on the clock as well
Fabi says I'm up two minutes let me just
play as best I can play some some solid
moves maybe a b6 now with that we don't
need four maybe not just be join me
three we saw a trade of rooks on the
e-file Maurice followed by rook d8 and
it's funny that we should be you know
harping a little bit about the knight
stability on d5 but you gotta admire
Magnus is doing he's protecting that 94
holy-o's word I was thinking I was
thinking something like a5 and night b4
as well to challenge this night even
though I we gonna be six square I'm not
totally happy
but we know expose Kings when Queen and
rook endings even if I have to shut up
on let's say my beep on for example I'm
willing to do that in order to get to
this sort of ending g6 played I'm not a
fan that what does be a movie could be
for as I see it like it's it goes with
Jen's idea she wants to use her majority
to attack and to me that's really really
logical and I'm I'm worried for fabbi
that f5 is it's going to be menacing so
we have u6 we have g6 but after g6 not
only do you have to worry about a 5 but
we also have the less positional but
potentially deadly scary move g5 as well
just locking into the desk at 6 square
right you are King f8 and
the reason for g6 is if you intended to
play King f8 and rook e8 and trade the
majors you had to make sure that Queen
takes h7 wasn't lopping off upon so here
we have King up on the board and you
know we didn't get a chance to talk
about it but Magnus earlier in the game
did make the decision to play King g1
and not King g2 and I wanted to draw
attention to it because I did not
understand them of king g1 I thought the
king was actually better and safer on g2
it was at a time that the Queen could
have come to h3 as well so now that our
opponent is played King f8 I would just
be inclined to play King G to bring my
king up the board and guess what I'm
sorry to say that I'm just a little bit
behind the players because I think
that's what Magnus did he played King f2
I beg your pardon
King g7 a very very bad sign it means
that fabbi doesn't know what to do he's
talking about what to do yet it's two
minutes to one minute right now what you
do is you play the most reasonable move
when you have no idea and let the guy
figure it out while you're looking
around and until Magnus figures it out
it's it's too much time to be burning
looking at what to do figure out
something solid now Magnus has put it
spawned on g5 is this crushing is this
something that's gonna do damage Fabi
now has to be alert in this moment
because he could trade off materi with
rook e8
what's the deal with that ending f8 Age
3
well sorry you said the pawn is on g5 I
don't have that updated on my board I
have an h3 is the last move
oh my apologies no it's it is fabi's
turn age sternum okay sorry I was
analyzing actually no so this is the
position what a basic soundboard a6
usually you don't touch pawns when
you're waiting around
that's another principle a6 I'm a little
afraid of that creates a really big
weakness and Magnus is being Zuke's
bonging with his King again challenging
Fabi to find a good move notice the
clock times are almost even now 114 for
Fabi 47
and so Magnus Mac Fabi still has a lead
he has to dare Magnus to find a move if
he doesn't see what to do and Magnus is
now offered a trade of Queens with the
move Queen to e6 not that is finally
something very concrete to play and Fabi
has traded Queens and played King to f7
attack in the room exactly okay I feel a
little bit of relief now is Fabi I was
getting afraid I was gonna get f5 and
check right now only like me I can
consolidate things like I'm even
dreaming of playing like d3 and you take
my con I clean night before check and I
I draw the endgame I don't know guys I
would be fine as Masha just pointed out
yeah b5 right away not now know that the
night I've seen oh yeah yeah I still I
mean error like b5 worker c6 takes on c4
you stop to calculate a little head yeah
I'm one of those guys I I just love
space I love we played rook to g8 going
nowhere woah allowed allowed Magnus a
free free move in that position
we're not sure what rook g8 threatens
but Magnus plays rook eight-six
immediately and look at this and this is
what I was worried about when you don't
have much to do you've got to reset your
brain and let the clock be your friend
and he let Magnus now have a leap
remember that five minute edge was five
minutes he instead played some moves
Magnus played his same moves he was
gonna play anyway and now fabi's down to
26 seconds - Magnus is 48
that's absolutely remarkable I mean just
remind me it's a terrible position for
fab' he doesn't have active play I keep
I keep talking about active play and
putting together a pair plan he doesn't
have an active plan he doesn't have
active play I should say and for me all
of Wight's pieces if you just do a
comparison check the King's edge white
definitely reg white why ever
and by the way we're in the time
scramble now 17 seconds left for Fabi as
96 check was just played and now the
pawn on g3 disappears
four points for wife refunds for flags
but 97 just played threatening Rick
takes e4 can't we just play working d4 I
would play c5 I like the night sitting
snugly on the e6 square but I have to be
careful mindful I mean to say about the
move King f6 maybe I have to play Knight
check first before deciding how I'm best
going to defend the pawn he's playing
because now King at 6 there's work d6
Jack were thinking g7 there's at $6.99
Bobby no way we see King back to e8 and
now I'm sorry Jen you wanted to play
rook d4 to just defend the pawn looks
like a good move to me can can I go what
about just taking on h7 and starting to
push the the F pawn that looks good -
I'm all for that rook takes pardon me
Knight takes rook takes how would it go
King g5
yeah q g5 exactly like and then you
probably want to try work c5 there but
instead it
Magne just started marching right away
with King to e5 ke5 allowing rook c5
check what's the point of this the point
is there a mate some way and I four
seconds is Fabi two seconds seven okay
what's the deal why did Magnus give this
away because knight Knight 2 G and they
play 94 in 97 check qingxue
d6 and it's taking the safe of me
monopod thrown this away in fabi's time
pressure and it's Magnus who's down on
the clock and is now thinking of making
it I'm pressure folks makes fools of us
all including the star players
it's about your clock handling and
feeling
pressure in the moment and both of them
have felt it including Magnus now Fabi
can think maybe I can try to finagle a
win
well that is upon up yeah true words yes
but look at that active King on e5 Yoli
he's gonna figure out a way 95
always check the White King backwards
and he did that and now we know that
that's too much that now it's a draw
well now we thinking 95 but the problem
is that even a mastery we are gonna be
close enough to make that draw with the
a pawns I mean where the H with the
pawns this is gonna weigh now you know
yeah sure I mean as they continue to
play this is still definitely a draw and
they both relaxed now as they know it
yes sir
you were showing how beautiful the
position was for white and of course you
were a hundred percent right no doubt
about it in the objective world white
was dominating in that position but when
you're playing the the clock when you're
playing under these kind of conditions
despite the beauty I mean beautiful
winning Magnus was just winning time has
to be calculated as a part of these
games they just just do and you can look
at why you see white is up when I
clicked off the deep on especially this
was toast this objectively was toast but
you've got to give pressure on the guy
when you're worse when you're in
defending don't start looking for active
play when you realize you don't have it
make a few moves look around for his
active chances and see what maybe you'll
get something later in the game probably
a lot is time to take all the way down
five minutes disappeared looking around
for stuff to do
he was very fortunate Magnus didn't win
this game no question about that I'm
still in I mean Magnus has made a very
good living off of winning positions not
even as good as this one he had a really
good position after the move m5g / -
yeah we get down here to move 43 but and
this is a score guys after one
but we definitely have a lot of
incitement and in store for us at the
magic continues like bad guys I mean
they were playing too just seconds at
the end so of course even the top
players in the world would make mistakes
you just gotta get a move on the bird
you don't want to lose on time and
that's what that time scramble was about
absolutely well I just got to draw our
attention to this moment where Magnus
played the move rook takes d3 and
frankly I'm a bit surprised by that I
think a lot of grandmasters would have
gone for the night g5 check first the
idea is that you know your rook on d6
controls the f6 squared you want to make
sure that the king the black king
remains you know passive right like
backwards like it's great if you could
get the King for argument's sake to go
to to g7 when you could push the the
pawn with a tempo and after it moved
like Knight g5 I don't know what you're
supposed to do with life let's just play
a move here King here now actually you
know it's not like the D pawn is going
anywhere but your F Mahon just might win
the game I would have thought that the
move Knight g5 you know you got to look
at checks first right I mean they're the
biggest threats you can make in a game
of chess as a check so you gotta look at
and that check to me just like that
flashes in my mind I don't see anything
else except for rook takes d3 which was
quite so big miss by my Magnuson in my
view man opening opening but may I ask
you or remind you guys we've seen Wesley
so go three pawns up yep
do you think this one is worse than the
ones that Wesley failed to win couple of
times he was three pawns up and failed
to win right we've seen position we saw
Bobby against Wesley that game where he
was completely dominant in the opening
who was on one in this event right now
just gambit no this one was not that bad
for a blitz massa and we teeth are I'm
saying that's what we intend this
this is blitz so you have to combine the
good moves with the quick moves with the
time management with not feeling that
pressure and the thing is we we used to
say back in Brooklyn listen it's not
it's not about the clock it's not about
the play I hate it's really how you
handle that clock when the pressures
coming you know guys used to start
making moves that were closer to the
clock like when you look closer to the
clock when you have to press it move
your rook over here where I'm closer to
the clock all those little tricks is you
will handle the time situation and the
pressure just simply is there its
present Magnus has played Fabi before it
was excited about winning the game and
what a great start it would be even the
best of the best or draw games they
should have won or lose games they
should have learned how are we feeling
about our predictions after just one
game it's too early in my opinion I'm
feeling great no on the contrary I think
fabbi dodged a bullet so I'm feeling
like fab ease I'm happy I'm happy for
fabbi that he got a draw my game I
really am I think he's that ending
Magnus should win it nine out of ten
times oh yeah absolutely absolutely I
agree with that although sometimes that
10% er comes in guys right that's right
more often minute the 10% merits the
issue is what effect does that game have
on the rest of the match now does that
she does bankers just go and whatever
this guy here and stay with me or does
probably say yeah you know I got a bad
position and I still came back maybe you
know that in for semi matches those
semi-final matches the opening games
those games seven for example in those
games one of those matches dictated the
shock that the day's play if you dinner
if the rest of the match exactly exactly
and well I mean a draw to open the
accounts for both players
Wow I don't know I think Abby's happy
9:8 Magnus's maybe a little bit growl
hopping mad is what he is he walked out
of there I said what that's my that was
my chicken or beef or sushi or whatever
he enjoys in Norway I know they're great
they're famous for their salmon yeah man
yeah I heard the words had a lot of
salmon in the Norwegian Olympiad right
the one in uh what not whatever whatever
it is that he enjoys I'm pretty sure
he's not vegan
whatever he enjoys he felt like he was
taken out of his mouth
this last okay here we are we're off
they go Fabiana let's see this nope no I
was wrong already yeah we say our Berlin
is on the board and avoiding the Berlin
endgame is Fabiano exactly no Berlin end
game and no anti Berlin with tassels and
rookie one so in many ways this
variation really does transpose
transpose to a kind of a joke Oh piano
for those of you who play the Bishop c4
Bishop c5 variations you'll likely see
position to go oh I know this as a lot
of the variations of the open e 45
classical are transpositional Bishop d7
in this particular line this knight on
c6 often is seeking to migrate to the
king site by a c7 in g6 which is what's
happened and I gotta say guys we're
seeing some high elite preparation let's
say no know that King F 2 in this game
strange coming out the gate this is
definitely one of those you might look
at and see them play 30 moves and in the
end or maybe 35 and say draw draw a
bicycle chess of course
my are not laying playing classical we
are playing combo rapid blitz ish kind
of play and why looking for his little
something and like playing all the moves
that we all could have played and
pretended we were geniuses with these
moves so funny on the shoulder of giants
with yes motifs like a 492 Knight f12 g3
- to fixate on that f5 square and I like
these openings a lot because usually
tactics kind of pops off and maybe move
40 more moves 35 and really it's a
cliche but this type of position the
better the player who plays better wins
it's it's very strategic and I find that
we're gonna really see who's in form
this game well I was curious because I
wanted to say why usually aims for d4
that's white stays back with the pawn on
d3 and eventually says sooner or later I
put it on d4 and black needs to respond
to this expansion and he played d4
immediately so we do have what is just
one of those positions yeah a couple of
things that jump out when you play the
move d4 in these types of setups one of
the things you've always got to keep in
mind is can my opponent play d5 like I
know it looks ridiculous but oftentimes
if your opponent is able to get in the
move d4 d5 he equalizes quickly if you
don't play a d5 another approach is to
take an attacking approach in the center
and either force the MOE c5 and you'll
play c4 or once you play c5 open up the
sefa magnus has gone to door number 3 he
said I will take your phone on a 4 and
that no doubt was a very big surprise
for fabbi because normally speaking
you're not so classical rule say you
know don't separate your pawns keep your
pawns intact with one another and if
Abby said look I've studied my classics
I'll play Bishop takes
take for me pawn takes in the center
seating white you know the central pawn
duo if Abby says what are you doing
Magnus says I'm doing this I'm trading
bishops and I'm trading Queens
why did father Trey means though I feel
like when you have the center you have
space at least this is how I understand
things you have the center you have
space your opponent is fighting for air
the more trades you make unless you have
some really concrete thing like his a
pawn for example is such a big weakness
that you're gonna be able to pile up on
it with doubling rooks and he's gonna
put up on an a5 of course and bring
something over to d2 and he's not gonna
have counter play but it just feels like
you you let some of some of the
advantage go by giving him a chance to
not worry about space anymore now he
gets to just play against the position
and I'm I'm not a fan of whites a
black's pawn structure but i liked it so
much they keep space keep Queens on the
board and maintain that space hearing
from very well that he he says when like
that Queen exchange either the engine
didn't like that exchange either we see
Magnus again lounging backwards showing
that he likes the shorts when he's in
her likes the shirts
he likes the shorts and he's just
relaxed folks he's just completely
relaxed playing this position he
certainly is and he's just played the
move d5 taking a stab at white center
and saying okay go ahead play the movie
for if you like I'm gonna undermine the
e pawn with the move c5 fabbi said okay
I got a take now I've been like thinking
that this Knight has got to come to f5
really really fast and it's happened
after Knight f6 d6 by white black
recaptured and we've seen
five better 9.5 yeah I don't see too
much in this for white actually you know
comparatively speaking the Knights look
okay a little bit of an edge for white
with this night but the night is
wonderful in a middle game because it
leads to sacrifices on h6 and g7 in an
end game it doesn't really pack the same
punch where's my queen could I have it
back so I can sack something please that
h6 sack would be so scrumptious at some
point I'd be threatening ideas but the
Queen's are off now it's just about
precise endgame technique rook to e6
plate it looks like an awkward square
for that rook but it's probably
temporary the the only thing is for the
moment white is attacking the pawn on d6
and white is attacking the pawn on a6 so
he's played rook to c1 and he said look
you're not attacking anybody I'm the one
who has you looking at the pressure on
your buttons so maybe I'm not better
this pawn structure is very symmetrical
d-line over its be versus a but I'm the
one right now with the little pressure
you have to pay attention that's it now
is that enough to beat Magnus Carlsen
well Magnus has eight minutes on the
clock and again is looking pretty
relaxed so it's it's it's it's enough
for white to feel like well I'm not
worse who's this any time soon well
let's part start with a concrete no
something like a five right I mean you
mentioned that hey look man I don't like
this pressure on the a6 pawn let me play
a five I on a good day play rook b8 now
kind of counter punch you a little bit
mm-hmm against b2 if you join if you go
down and say hey ha I got the old double
attack you're in trouble
I'll go d5 and that solved two pawns in
two moves right that's pretty useful
sequence right there for sure so yeah I
just didn't know how I mean I
they whites a smidge for choice just
it's temporary but I do feel that white
rooks are a little bit more active to a
rook on a one versus a eight and the
rook on c1 versus the one on a six I
just don't know
concretely you know how to make things
work I'd love to be able to make a
tactic work with a d4 d5 push I just
don't see it we he's four week piece for
white two week pieces as we're
discussing it as Bishop to d8 avoiding
the rook c6 by putting the bishop on a
very odd square on the back row that's a
deep retreat putting your bishop all the
way to the eight where if you ask well
where's the bishop going to go now you
say I'm not really sure is he looking
for ninety seven right so what happens
on rook c6 now the same rook c6 which
attacks two pawns it's a 2/4 you don't
get to play d5 yeah exactly I mean I do
understand the move again you know like
I'm a simple guy I like to think in very
simple strategic terms
I always make these peace comparisons
and I say you know which pieces are
working and to my mind a knight on f5 is
it a beast so the move Bishop d8
prepares to trade it off with the move
Knight 7 so I can support that move and
we've seen by the way rook cease no no
yes yes yes don't we always haven't way
to back up like suppose you do trade the
knight on g6 for the one on f5 and then
after we take and play Knight h4 is it
in a case of we're getting our knight
back to f5 anyway deja vu I'm not sure
you're the the hope that question the
answer to that question revolves around
g7 g6 right so give me a move that you
like for white b43 I want to play rook a
reason is my first thing so 97 do you
want to go simply Knight h4 first
rather than show my cards right away
yeah so it often happens that I can't
boot the night when I got a pond sitting
on the h6 where it's really hard to get
rid of that so often times to get rid of
the night and play g6 I've got to first
preface it with h5 okay so now I want to
double in the sea line that was the
point of my play okay
I wouldn't have all the options either
to put the work on a file or or bring
this rook to the sea line I don't want
you to get a chance to breathe in a
position like this just to improve the
rooks instead another move deep retreats
one deep retreat deserves another you
play Bishop d8 I play Bishop d2 and the
2800 are giving us a lesson in
unorthodox moves as this move Bishop to
d2 was eyeing this square and magnus has
now played e5 I into a five square as
that arrow points out now d5 protects
the pawn will he play Bishop a5 or will
he play a move like rook c5 this this is
some interesting play by these players a
load still looks very equal even more
equal if he played the move Bishop to a5
in fact I think the bishop on d2 is
better than the bishop on d8
but now this night which I thought was a
problem for the longest it's finally had
an idea to go to e5 or at least an
avenue to get to e5 but he's decided
instead to head it to the c5 square and
played night to e1 another deep retreat
and a Magna saying okay enough for the
fancy retreating moose I'm just gonna go
forward Bobby just put a vision back to
e3 what's happening here confusion
reigns very hard to guess the last three
to three moves of fab' I didn't see
Bishop back to e3 coming I thought he
was planning to try to trade off the
dark swear bishops is my Bishop e3
oh oh there was a tactic as on the F
file you have to be mindful they have to
pawn was hanging after 94 it might have
been a right rook have six action if you
moved to Bishop away right so we for we
just don't want it with any appeal up on
your night 97 mm-hmm
well the question is after 97 you know
getting rid of White's best minor piece
which has occurred yeah I mean I start
to like Black Knight to deep black still
has weak buttons night to d3 threatens
Knight to f4 for one does I the C and
then which will be attacking the D pawn
does I the d5 square and that a6 pawn
stills on the board whites main deficit
is the B to pawn and rook v6 has been
played to attack it to remind white that
that pawn is indeed on the board but he
doesn't have great access to the d4 pawn
white however can play a move like rook
a 5 and press on the D pawn and say how
are you going to hold this position
together exactly
for now b2 is defended can you cover
everybody and by the way the clock times
are very different this game very even 5
minutes each and now King f1 on the
board this one I really understand I I
was seeing Ruby 3 as a threat and
attacking this night the night really
needs to stay rooted to defend the pawn
on the two so I like to move King f1
very much I like the idea of being able
to meet rook b3 with King e2 and after
King f1 Magnus is said okay rook b5
stopping the potential of rook a 5 and I
want to see 2 where C 2 is played just
your favorite concept over protecting b2
slings and arrows okay there is there is
another idea the knight on e4 will be
booted eventually by f3 the g3 square is
not that significant
but the night can end up on c4 and I'm
impressed by that night I will tell you
nothing that's a very nice piece
you don't like five because 93 Knight f5
could be interesting as well although I
the C 4 squared is very appealing
there's a there's some cool squares here
available for that night
Bishop to f6 now on the board maybe six
shooter both of them that's a thing I
know Knight d6 gives options
so both Oh squirty but Bishop the -
though is the moment you do things like
Bishop f6 and move your knight then
white gets to play Knight to c5 for free
so you do have to be mindful it's not
just white it's not just you will be
attacking that rook C to move over
protecting b2 was definitely had some
wisdom to it because it means the knight
can now move the knight on d3 can in
fact move at some point and before Wow
taking the pawn off of b2 and relegating
the night - on d3 - permanent duty
basically on d3 at the moment that's an
aggressive move I think he's looking for
rooks e6 that's what it is he's looking
for roots e60 want to tie this pawn down
first okay so if black region we
re-energizes his attack against the
b-pawn with this 57 then work' for mr.
bass there should be something I want to
play rock a4 with both ideas again he
asked play Bishop e7 and I'm just
thinking rook a for allows for rook c6
and for rook a - oh no rook 8 - is not
possible because a knight c3 right Sam
play rookie to identify rook c6 sorry
rook c6 rookie after work a4 if if we're
k4 now I mean yes we're okay for now
I see okay but I was saying defending
the pawn and playing for Rick c6 man
this is your move 32 yet if they trade
a couple of ponds we'd say high-class
game draw between monsters Rick a4 on
the board this is high-level chest
they've done all this in six minutes I
know the play for this game has been
remarkably fast paced exactly they're
playing great chess guys but we look
continue as the time the time he picks
down that's always the question right
before played we just saw in Game one
the time the clock making a mangled mess
of the position at the very end and a
very fortunate fortunate Fabiano to get
a draw their time is not a factor but
it's beginning to creep up on us I would
have thought that black would like to
play g5 and f5 and f4 and get something
going on the kingside he hasn't he's
just played well I don't want to say
mundane ly but you know I think
correctly attack a weakness weakness is
only a weakness is if it can be attacked
and the B part is under threat subtle
subtle distinctions now you could take
on a six allowed Bishop takes b4 that
does change the position and he did not
he played Bishop before first attacking
the rook and rook to in rook to b7
keeping that pressure but he's no longer
in the back rank is there any energy
she's a knight C 595 must take with
something in that lon
gets turned into a sexy pot okay that I
did then I'll change horses and say I
like white but sorry rook takes bi
birthday I'm so shocked that he noticed
so Ruby 7 is playable by the way fabi's
now under 3 minutes
Magnus at 3:40 Magnus was under five
each time and I think that Bobby was
surprised by this move and only now
notice
this possibility now he could just keep
things clean take him 86 and say I'm
trying to get out of here with with no
worry just take he's played f3 first
again that move told the night it had
tonight over on g5 heading to e6 I guess
I'd be happy to see that happen if I
were if I were white for sure well the
night on e6 had I mean it will be
attacking the pawn on d4 so the knight
on e4 look good but I just didn't know
exactly what it was attacking where's
the knight on e6 I mean that's quite
useful weed so quickly a trade on g5
apparently fabbi did not want to see the
knight land on e6 and so now this just
looks like a-- like well played draw
yeah looks like he has a lot less I
wasn't thrilled by seeing this move
Bishop takes on g5 v either this looks
like he left just let the air out of the
position the wonderful dynamics we were
seeing the tension was building it's
about time for him to sort of trade off
the buttons he could even defend his
pawn on beat on before with rook b2 and
that position would really balance
itself out sure this is not much anymore
Fabia down to 137 best bet Fabi make
your draw don't do anything crazy
right just get out of this position say
okay it's all good
you're at 128 it's clock is starting to
be your enemy just play straight forward
moves this is not an advantage for
either side here rook takes a6 Bishop
takes before instantly Magnus pressuring
him on the clock what a reversal of game
one where it was Magnus way behind on
the clock is it harder to play white
guys tiny bit harder just because you
know you don't want to take on before
and then like allow the work to attack
before and you think before you get
stuff I think was an existential
question you were asking right yeah
whether or not in this game but in
general because both times White was
down on the clock yeah what I see what
you're saying yeah well I do think that
you know in these rapid games we often
don't see a very high percentage for ye
Dewey it's um well that's why the
absurdity of Game one where Magnus you
know sa King F to early in the opening
is indicative of that trend that White's
not getting play in the position and so
sometimes you have to do something
absurd that hopefully isn't terrible I
mean you don't want to take you know
obscene chances you know overplaying
your hand and well I it turned into a
great fight actually for a game that had
such a strange oh bigoted a great fight
right away that the players are now in a
rook and pawn and Game two versus two
there I say it we're about to see the
match tied after two games yes that
2,800 struggle don't expect any blowouts
if you thought Magnus was just gonna
dominate this one mmm these two
all-stars these do it all starts Bobby
knows how to play and Fabi has brought
it Magnus has brought it maybe not the
most exciting
sizzling chess ever I was and it's like
it's encouraging because it shows that
we really gonna get a good match exactly
that's why we have heavy weights and
don't don't expect them to make
ridiculous ridiculous blunders you know
all the time Bobby did play a bad game
Game one though we must say he was lost
yeah oh pretty quick pretty quick pretty
brisk and we're waiting for the draw to
show up as they're now and move 58 right
they can accept the draw and move 60 and
I think they're just quickly trying to
get to it now because we have a rule in
the clutch chest either
that drawers cannot be offered before mu
60 right Jen
that's right move 60 and we've seen
people obviously figure out how to do
repetitions if it's a dead draw or
converse King that's another way is
gonna say okay
no play here their days their kids got
it got it it's kind of nice to see bare
kings in so many games it really does
show that fight to the end and you see
started off this match with tutorials
guys but don't worry III know there's
gonna be a decisive game today guys when
the blood first bill we will not see 12
draws like we did in the World
Championship no no no no we have a
special coming up for the viewers yes
and we're gonna take a little look at
Magnus Carlsen in some of his clutch
moments and there were many over the
years and we'll be back for Game three
in the last round of the inaugural
Sinquefield Cup in 2013 soon to be world
champion Magnus Carlsen declined to draw
offer that would have won him the
tournament the rest is history but these
guys might be getting fatigued and that
was where a lot of their interviews they
spoke about their stamina and the need
and it looks and looks like there might
have been a verbal offer of a draw in
this position and Magnus not twirling
upon the vine offer to drive and Magnus
is thinking about Berlin Magnus thinking
fascinated to see if he makes a move
with the fact that's his 70,000 has
literally been handed to him it's more
than just and he has made incredible
like the draw offer I decided to
continue with 70 grand in his pocket he
didn't win no more there's nothing
beneficial to him to making another move
absolutely nothing and he has actually
decided to continue playing and allowed
other results to enter and the night on
a one is trapped incredible lines but it
looks as though if Magnussen now plays
this move Knight to c4 after king d8 he
will be winning at least have a big
advantage and we have it and there it is
magnus carlsen is the ce field cup
winner the champion he's sleeping closer
to 2900 we have a comment on Twitter
that Magnus Carlsen turned let's draw
off her down that's by Michael waters
because he previously said he wanted to
be world champion and 2900 by the end of
2013 and he gets one step closer with
his victory at the same field cup
leaving him far ahead of his rivals and
securing the $70,000 the trophy and more
importantly I mean making a fabulous
impression to fans all over the world
[Music]
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value Ches
brings to our community in these times
of social distancing it's more important
than ever that we stay connected to
carry on that mission we are currently
offering 24 weekly classes online
through our YouTube and twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home students can enjoy all
the benefits of our scholastic chess
initiative digital our Scholastic
outreach continues with virtual chess
classrooms in scholastic tournaments and
scouts BSA maher beds workshops on
behalf of everyone at the st. knows
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play and enjoy the game of chess can you
hear it it's the sound of hope and
health
and strength it's the sound of
compassion of open doors where people
and machines are in tune and miracles
occur
it's a sound of personalized health care
and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear when you really listen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone and we are back for
clutch chest and we just started Game
three I thought this was gonna be the
first game that was decisive let's see
how my prediction there goes it looks
like we're getting did you say that I
always feel like Game three I got a big
game Gate three always feels like the
game that draws blood okay and Bishop f4
a London system opening for white I'm
thinking that Alexander Griffith you got
to give credit where credit is due
Pasha kind of really put Bishop f4 back
on the map and then II Carl Nakamura
kind of took it up and said you know
that's pretty good okay I like the
system and since that time it's actually
it's always been popular with club
players you just get your bishop out
from behind the pawn structure and you
get a very different game then maybe the
channels of I don't know and
nimzo-indian Queens gambit declined and
we always welcome new challenges and by
the way we after the move Bishop Knight
f9h five-part me we didn't see the
bishop retreating back or moving but
captures on c5 so we're hoping Magnus is
hoping that he can grab a pawn on c5
Queen it but Queen a five by F Abby says
haha this knight is pinned it ain't
going anywhere and I'll pick up the pawn
with Queen takes e5 being told by bar
that night h5 itself is actually pretty
rare at the highest levels it reminds me
of the game that Magnus played Geoffrey
where Magnus allowed Knight takes on f4
then put his in the game where he put
his Knight back on g1 from e2 and then
get his back on f3 then play Queen d2
and castles Queen side and blasted
Geoffrey I think it maybe gave him 12 of
the of clutch of the clutch chess of the
match they played game 11 or 12 he just
just said I'm just gonna play like this
and right in the game but certainly was
where you played 92 to g1 allowed Knight
a except for this way in Knight h5 9
except for and then went about his
business but Fabi said no no such luck
I'm not letting you get away that easy
with that attack and well magnets could
have maybe tried for it but he's
restraining the dark-squared bishop of
black with the move
c3 Fabi does have the two bishops but
mainly that bishop on the g7 square and
he's gonna want to somehow use it so
that he can show to Agnes hey look this
is a strong piece why'd you give me
yours
now I got mine right I also being told
that move 10 Knight b3 by Magnus was a
very new approach in fact never been
played before and that's hard to do
these days where we've got our database
so I don't care
810 million games to play something so
unique I move 10 is rare Bishop g4
basically saying okay move it or lose
move it and I'm expecting Magnus to play
94 now the question is would you give up
the dark square Bishop if you had if you
were given this position as guys I'm
taking notes here because I feel like
whenever I play a blitz game and
somebody plays the London and I get this
miserable position with no counter play
I'm looking at Bobby and I'm like wait a
second let's do this and you just have
to be precise and you have to be
prepared and suddenly this type of
opening doesn't have the teeth that it
does if you're just kind of making
automatic moves news for you Jim let's
say the st. Louis chess club has won 900
operators standing by or any of you out
there who have trouble with the London
299 a minute it's a different line than
our time time pressure addicts line
right right you get the right rate
extension so Queen III played and
actually that was a pretty cool move by
Magnus because the move actually has a
has a well do we want to call it a
threat I'd call it a threat the threat
is to move to e5 occupy by the darks
were followed by ninety four again
occupying dark squares and fabbi said
look let me just get rid of that thing
we've got bishops of opposite colors on
the board I'm gonna blame me six and if
anybody has a smidge of an advantage
a small whiff that is to say it's gonna
be black yeah look at the last two moves
each four by white trying to get that
alpha zero
esque layla s pawn down to the H five
eight six square I don't even see how it
gets the eight-six given that you have
this beautiful bishop but maybe just h5
and trade eventually but Bobby said no
can do I'm gonna stop that
Magnus log3 and rook e8 rook F to e8 at
the moment and both of them are still at
arm's length
no piece across the fourth rank at the
moment I think this entire game only
blacks bishop that went to g4 has
crossed the fourth rank in this game yes
a line of demarkation has been pretty
severe and this is what I spoke about
when I was referring to the opening Fred
I in Game one I mean this unfortunately
is a terrible example of what the elite
players are facing I mean there's no
play in the position for white here this
position in my view is really really
even Stephens I mean black will probably
bring his rook to the center and move
his Queen back and say okay I don't know
where we're punching one another but
nobody's going up so that's why I am
saying that that that approach that
Magnus took in Game one
you know you respect it even as you're
kind of teasing it and saying you know
that's pretty ridiculous you're going to
extremes b5 an aggressor Hey look at
this an immediate late
yes with the idea that after pawn takes
e4 Bishop takes e4 and not only re
attacking your queen but we're ready to
take on c6 and fourth gear up so that's
night it's taboo instantly by the way he
played it instantly now sitting up in
his chair he was leaning back before but
he feels like oh got a little trick off
he's knock the night he wants to get it
to g5 which was an a which which 92
couldn't do he couldn't play 94 in the
previous move because you just get it
captured so the knight goes back to D to
the it's almost like he read his
opponents mind b5 lines on the board and
Magnus instantly talked about an alert
assassin this guy's so alert as soon as
the paulandan b5 he said oh now I can do
this and 94 just hang down on the board
and suddenly Fabi goes uh well I didn't
see that one I thought I was doing
something you can't even try any
aggressive moves against these guys they
come up with instantaneous tactics and
that one that's cause Robbie to go into
a thing
by the way I was mistaken the black
knight did play Knight from h5 takes on
f4 crossing the demarcation line earlier
as well so only black so far has put
anything across that 4th rank that is a
kissable line separating the two forces
along the 4th rank but Magnus now with
the ability to go to g5 he's gonna be
part on that Square I mean part you're
not gonna play f6 that's starting to get
a little scary not anytime soon that's
for sure the other problem is that from
blacks point of view is there there are
sacrifices now that this knight got to
this really wonderful square over here
on the kingside their sacrifices that
you've always got to be careful about
asian dings is one of them I mean
especially now that I walked into a for
shame on me but even if it wasn't for
the bishop let's say well for the work
for because the night is here we could
parlay that also with ideas of h5
I like that's what I'm like I think
that's where Fabi started to panic now
Ealing open the position on the kingside
a bit so there dangers I mean it's it's
nothing terrible but there's some danger
alerts we we do have Queen d7 on the
board by the way Knight g5 and Abby said
okay that minority attack was just a
bluff I I just put on up there to
restrain you and by the way d5 deef no
no d5 before would walk into Bishop c4
sorry about that okay Bishop C - no g4
listen that and I didn't deserve I'm
gonna I didn't deserve to get to g5
Bobby and I'm not happy with himself and
Magnus was very alert he's a he's aware
of the moment and be for ignoring the g4
idea again Bishop c2 was so that you I
think against g4 yeah yes he was maybe
concerned of an e5 idea just a second so
rook e8 g for concerned about 85 oh yeah
i wanted i wanted to oh well if i was
also it is a real tempo as well but i
thought he could take and then play d5
that's what's my concern makes sense
make sense and you're you're still you
you know he gets the break just when he
needs it and here your pawn on f7 s f5
is actually hanging so and pinned i
can't quite take it maybe i can i play
e4 i mean this is not possible okay what
about what about 97 going after the pawn
Knight then we run a try night after
that
we sure do right just my spidey senses
are tingling as well and i got you yes I
see the mate though the king will drop
back where does the King okay you're
only a tiger with one piece I can't get
my work into e3 but it is it is fun time
position a for though that's the other
thing about the move before it opens up
with that diagonal so it says Magnus
let's the sides of the board who would
have thought that let's get back to the
position at hand because this move
Bishop a4 that when the bishop dropped
back I think Magnus had this idea well I
can come back to g4 mm-hmm
I will sidestep the impact of any e5 my
my bishop might be on the way by the way
the rook has kind of opened up so I I
appreciate the the move Bishop see to
the moon before was a little surprising
because allowing this pin I don't know
guys that might not have been the best
thing to do to allow because wait a
minute this could be really annoying
Queen c8 played and what is like is
really dis coordinating his forces sorry
I mean g4 is back in business
is there an f5 in for the H pawn or the
D pawn hey that's a trade I like because
even if you play if you play
f5 your move move Maurice and then he
takes f5 suddenly the f7 square is
access to the light squares actually I'm
just thinking dominate the light squares
because you've got an opposite color
Bishop position and you can dominate the
light squares that looks like toast
I think and we're being told
f5 wins you want
there it is Grand Prix babe he just
reminds me of the type of move you
playing the Grand Prix that just blows
everything open actually after he takes
a 5 is it rook takes the 8 work takes
you eight community five just that's
your cracking the lights remember it's
opposite Khalid Bishop so the light
square bishop is going to be king if you
make this Bishop into a real piece
you're gonna get crushed the bishop on
g7 is wondering what it's going to be
active but if what if one side gets an
attack on that opposite color then the
bishop of the other color cannot help
and here we
everything it's just that diagram you're
showing signs scissor action everywhere
you're just busted so it's pretty sad
Murray's that I probably survived longer
if I take with the Jeep on then they
epon that's the very side that's not I'm
know if I was a killer you have to take
I think you have to take with the Jeep
on because your whole position is coming
crumbling down any second and he did
decide that's what he's going to do boy
this looks not a happy circle Fabiana
missed he missed 94 on a protected
square upon we talked about this often
squares that are protected by pawns are
often invisible not noticed hidden to
even very strong players and Fabi
thought I'm covering e4 oh wait a minute
a knight just landed on e4 then later
I'm covering at five oh wait a minute
upon just landed on f5 the two moves
that have blown that have caused him one
positionally to go down and two
tactically to be in a world of hurt I've
been on squares that were seemingly
perfectly covered by pawns and turns out
Magnus was alert to the fact that they
weren't and look at this Magnus don't
even take on h5 right away he wants more
yummies Z for another light-square
attacking move it's actually funny
because I did not see the move f5 going
back just to this moment maybe in a
classical game it would have occurred to
me but I did see the move c4 because I
was thinking you know like let's parlay
that pin on the knight on c6 into an
attack
so I was thinking c4 all the way when
you guys pointed out how powerful f5 is
I said yummy and it's kind of funny we
both get in the same break the the the
attacks that we wanted c4 on the board
immediately your eyes we've been drawn
to the move c4 be able to win upon
versus gifting upon away it took 26
moves he took 26 moves to play your
favorite first movie as right better
late than never
as c4 on the board
again a square that upon is guarding but
in this case you because you don't want
to capture on c4 and drop your knight on
c6 or I mean everything is falling apart
forget it so this position is crushing
it looks like what to do as black this
is a masterpiece by Magnus if Magnus go
Xhosa
and wins this game which it looks to all
eyes that he should this will be one of
those that we point to in the articles
and say wow wow he's got in this
position in five minutes and 14 seconds
okay some increments as well but he has
just completely outplayed his opponent
and now 9k for desperation it I wanted
to say let's see how bad it is 94 attack
the Queen so the idea is if you take my
pawn
then I rescue myself I don't allow
checkmate in wand and right with rook f8
but I didn't know that f7 and I do get
out of Dodge so 94 probably we're gonna
see rook takes d4 that nice got ad I
cannot last another man we're gonna see
Bishop takes because now we're
threatening to take so so far so good
and what do we got at the end of the day
take on age 5 and a mating attack that
looks vicious is it main to Queen f7 is
mate so so we could also take on d5 okay
you like take on h5 I'll defend against
and now take on d5 and then we went back
both for now we're actually up upon
despite everything we're ahead by a pawn
and everything in your position is
collapsing I mean that's that's a pawn
after your own heart yes yeah I'm just a
little bit worried about some counter
schpeel probably it's not enough but
what else is fab you gonna do if not for
Knight d4 it's absurd a plea all happen
rook d4 [ __ ] would be for Queen age 5
has happened and Bishop e8 did happen as
well so we we don't have rookies 7 on
the board yet we don't have rookies so
that we don't oh ok
this is
even material at the moment expose
king/queen upon Quincy's have been
played and mean see seven okay
by the way alert alert alert you know
don't it that comes with a double at a
dirty rat alright so i don't want to
play dirty black queen eat seven and
makes six no because then work a six
ricky six and then your move yes right
he just ignored the threats d5 he said
you can crash in on g3 if you like king
h1 no more checks and i'm going to make
you or your position collapses oh by the
way thanks for the G file oh my goodness
C takes d5 triple exclamation mark
giving an explosive Queen g3 that is
boss I'm sorry that's amazing well it's
one of those annotations that Alexander
Alekhine made in his best games
collection he shows a position and his
opponent
you know plays a move like Queen c7 with
this monster threat of Queen takes g3
and Alec kind says you know he goes
through all the permutations you know
like how would this move terrified him
and everything and then he says well
what if I let my opponent you know
continue with this threat and it's like
do what you want to do and her Aikido
chess by the way give the guy his move
and then make him pay for it and the
more the more for sceneline instead of
allowing allowing Queen takes g3 doesn't
work because suddenly the Queen and the
knight don't do defensive Duty anymore
so if you were to try to really 1887
check in Knight takes c6 winning in
exchange because there's pins suddenly
look at how both of those pieces
disappeared from the defense right so
and now we're actually not when g3 is
too strong on the line and
Fabia's just swallowed his pride and
said Ruki 7 I can't go for Queen G 3
maybe I'll get it later in the game but
he did drop a pawn and rookie 7 looks I
mean that Bishop on d4 is just stopping
the mates but is it changing anything if
if you took on e6 immediately then 6 hmm
takes on e6 immediately it's good too
why not look good Queen g3 doesn't do
anything and Magnus is going right ahead
got it you want to play your check it's
not going to matter I got all the same
goodies and now f6 is on the board f6
trying to chance now chase tonight
there's no check anymore on on what
about 7 but this Queen has been prayed
and by the way I can defend g3 by just
retreating the night now I mean there's
no one to I so don't want to play Knight
f3 although it does do the job you feel
like there's a knocking such such brutal
chess so far that you want to go get the
guy somehow but and now it may be time
to just choose 6 Jack for instance but
we just came from there right yeah 77
Jack maybe it's time to be wise and just
installed a the possession showed that I
can't play what's that sorry oh if you
play rook g7 after here after instead of
King g8 I do have the e7 Jack in the
hall yeah oh that's killer that's a
killer blow hello yeah
all right well looks like we have to
play a retreating move Knight of three
consolidate everything not just it's not
just the retreating move it's just like
man acts that's a blow in itself I mean
I agree with you it'd be great to win
the game spectacularly with Knight h7
check and a 7 but made of three you know
like if you look at it you go oh my word
it does everything it defends the g3
part he spent the long
before you finally played it by the way
he's quite reluctant I understand and
bring it back
but now Fabia on so Bishop c3 on the
board you would think the rook probably
will go to c1 and pin and say what are
you doing with your pieces although that
east six pawn is going to I can't
believe that yeah rook III you want to
play yes pretty much
everything should do the job he did for
a rook to c1 and rook takes on e6 played
94 as possible that's a nice tactical
alert Knight d4 take yeah I didn't want
to take on f5 with the night yeah the
night would be juicy and look at that
yeah channeling magnus carlsen
our former US Champion there wow wow in
a quirky five I'm just gonna take one at
six with Jack's yeah you know what we've
just seen 35 moves and if Magnus played
this in a classical game you'd say wow
you would actually go wow when you saw
was a good class that was a nice game
he's done this in nine minutes he's just
making Fabi look bad we're not talking
about the number fiftieth player in the
world fiftieth no we're not talking
about a number thirty player we're not
talking about the number ten player
we're talking about the number two
player in the world and he is making
this just look so easy effortless
effortless he's thrown in a check on
eight six because you can't play clean
for seven and now he's just late Queen
III they just pick up but what about we
offer Bishop d4 there's Queenie a check
in between moves
oh that's just resigns and there it is
no point resins that Knight is covering
any square that you might try to touch
to connect with the bishop what a
performance by Magnus game three you
were right Jen Game three there's
something about game previews
they're warmed up but they're not too
tired
any data analysis it is always feels
that way I'm have to go check via the
the data on it as well
commentators intuition it comes with me
to Vegas Jen I like your intuition was
special
and hearing the finals we've got the
current situation right shoot wait for
Magnus Carlsen with Fabiano Carolina one
one point so beautiful game for Magnus
but what really matters are those clutch
games later today and remember that if
Bobby can strike back and one of them he
will leapfrog Magnus crosnes for Wow by
the way we see here the clutch bonus to
date we saw on that graphic magnet ten
grand but the leader was Wesley so with
12 so Wesley took home the semi-final
prize of twenty seven twenty five
thousand plus another twelve that puts
him at 37 thousand so whoever loses this
match will take 35 but also already has
money as well so they will have passed
Wesley November 1 and we just take a
look at the money there's a lot of money
it's taking this match but because of
the semi finals in the clutch money from
the quarters which was won one game sent
some money forward and two of them in
the semi finals which added together
through 20,000 sprinkled on two games
clutch games 11 and 12 so instead of
them being were three thousand tomorrow
there will be worth 13 thousand if you
add that up and get 26 as we mentioned
before we had another four four games
five and six today that's $30,000 extra
added to the pool for these players but
let me tell you that might be sparkling
but nothing was as sparkling when we
just saw you take a 10-minute game
played with style with with precision
maybe not maybe precision might be too
much I'd have to check the engines to
say whether or not it was the top top
precision but you saw I play it like
like it got the knife out and he said
sit here I want to do it to you
here I'm gonna do it on the queenside
I'm gonna I'm gonna put a night on 84th
minute cycling on on f5 then I'm gonna
sack on c4 I'm gonna break into your
position I'm gonna let you take on g3 if
you want to and I'm gonna come back and
when your bishop it was just like style
points it was like a basketball player
dribbling between the legs behind the
back up forward backward broke your
ankles drove to the hoop easy layup Who
am I playing against I mean it was just
so artistic and at the same time brutal
amazing play by Magnussen Game three for
me the remarkable I'll just show the
position after moved 22 I thought that
if anybody had an edge it was actually
fabbi right here I preferred Faddis palm
structure I liked the fact that he has
this minority attack and after it moved
like Bishop c2 Queen c7 I'm thinking the
game is going to be more of a draw than
anything because of the opposite color
Bishop effect but this was actually one
move one move turned the tables instead
of Queens he said Knight e4 it was the
move this five yeah bee farm yeah no it
was b5 that that was the easy to play
Queen c7 before the move be five but it
was like 94 and then even this position
looks fairly innocent and it was just
like over before you knew it maybe this
was also a culprit of a movie or yeah us
to plan both sides of the board with
Bishop a4 and now you have to watch out
for c4 an f5 so instructed that before
seems like an active move but it
actually gave more activity to white and
black and you know the flip side I've
got to give squares to get squares
exactly I didn't get some squares and
you give away too many I'm trying this
reminds me of Aikido over and over you
make an aggressive move this is what no
I did a DVD on this a chess base or
called the secret to chess you make an
aggressive move but their drawbacks to
every move you make and you have to be
mindful of what the drawback is and in
that game the b5 move we can see 6 then
the b4 move we can then AG you know and
the top
players like icy your weakness I see it
again I exploited again and Magnus just
showed what happens when you think
you're being aggressive only to find out
that those aggressive moves are creating
problems in your own position that was a
masterpiece if Magnus wins this I'm
going to go out on a limb and say if
Magnus wins this match this game 3 is
the one everyone he's gonna publish or
at least everybody who's writing already
know they've got a game a lot of great
writers out there a we could quote I
know one John Henderson who's oh I get
his articles in my inbox The Scotsman he
already know he's thinking forget the
other three games
let me start annotating now by the way
she does
clutch chess highlights after the games
are over on YouTube and I agree with you
Maurice I think she's gonna focus more
in that game than the first day yeah no
I mean even the next three I don't think
then how can you get a better game that
we just saw this we get highlight games
yeah yeah it had it all for just the
execution give me that give me that take
him down take him down beautiful game by
magnets by the way game ten one of the
beautiful things about it is that a
player like Fabiano can make that kind
of strategic / oversight whereas in a
classical game I don't think he would
play before because of this Bishop a4
the idea he noticed it and he would
avoid it so in terms of openings and
calculating sometimes they seem almost
the same in certain game tends as they
would in classical but those types of
judgment calls can eclipse their vision
yes easily easily no question about it
and this time control look nobody's
gonna play perfectly Magnus here that
nobody's gonna play further please Kay
game really really close and they're
hard game good for the clutch game and
we switched to the Rasul emo as well
rather magnet switch to the Sicilian
from wo King pawn and now we've got
a wrassle emo which we saw so much of in
their World Championship at London yeah
we've already not mimicked the World
Championship as that one ended in 12
draws this one won't thank goodness we
have seen one victory so far and I was
in Game three as you predicted Jennifer
and wow that's this match is really
showing us some stuff already we don't
want Fabi to just get run over though if
Magnus keeps playing like that you're
good no okay what am I gonna do yeah
this guy's too good let's see let's hold
bad Bobby can find some some tooth in
the play well here's one that he's
carrying a twine this position I'm
trying to recall it what I believe it
was from a vikon's a here in Holland the
Tata Steel masters competition between
onigiri Holland's number one player was
white Magnus Carlsen was black and they
played a position that featured this
setup and Magnus won a remarkable game
certainly that would have been familiar
are you are you referring to my kinds a
icons they are Zagreb where Magnus lady
sings
yeah okay remember that he plays these
six completely anti positional d6 gave
and beat mag and beat and somehow maybe
he took an H pawn as well and then he
ran his aged pawn down the board and
beat a niche in like twenty three moose
I exactly that's the guy I missed it was
in the grand chest [ __ ] right the
Zagreb is not where you worried that yes
I was there watched it we were stunned
with Magnus played e6 you said he could
do that why I said yeah you know I
thought I can mix it up not go down the
guys prep and he turned out just play
some vicious chess with the black pieces
and I've seen that from Magnus Magnusson
this is Sicilian then I start attacking
them and he just works now this is going
to be a monstrously difficult task
for all of those brilliant chess writers
you mentioned Maurice to annotate how do
you annotate a game where white castles
short okay fair enough
white castle sure that's what he did
okay and then place h4 h5 spot of the
board on the same flag Betty Castle this
king he purposefully weakens his poncho
and then yeah and then he gonna finish
no that's Annie plays Knight h2 with
none of the other pieces developed on
the other side of the board is a bank
sitting on b1 and disciplines on c1 and
this Knight says I'm going to an
inferior square h2 got towards the
center I'm like trying to hide my knight
Bishop g4 of course was a problem after
the last move d6 we understand that but
if you looked at this if you saw night
h2 if you saw this position with white
and your student who was about 1800 was
playing you'd say are you having a bad
day you never play like this what are
you doing today yeah and you know it's
so funny guys cuz one of the things I
was about to make a big speech about was
that how I feel the game 10 with the
best players in the world is so good for
students because they actually make
mistakes so you can kind of see it just
like you know how some people say look
at the classics because another great
games beautiful but they didn't have as
many high shoulders to stand on because
there wasn't a garry kasparov or an Alec
I'm or a sinus yet so go way way back
and those games are really instructive
you can say that same thing about game
of how you're saying there may be
players in the world your sake you're
making mistakes that's a judgment Jen
I'm not saying they're making mistakes
because I don't know
I'm not saying in this position that
these h4 moves are def are mistakes but
I think for beginners you know it's a
little bit much to try to understand
you're trying to explain the classic
principles of development right right
right
they don't that's what I'm saying is if
it's
if you've been you know drilled let's
put it that way drilled at the classics
you know bring your pieces out make sure
everybody's developed keep your kings
protected don't move the same piece
twice and you've been drilled in these
principles where where where coaches of
principles right we we we we adhere to
them dearly and all the principles are
getting broken currently loves to play
h4 h5 h6 I mean you know a lot of the
top players are training with Leela
which is the open source version but
this type of a I and III c h4 h5 h6 even
more often because often much more often
it's now in it's not just in everybody's
repertoire and it's almost like you have
to say yes you want to develop your
pieces yes bring everything to the
center castle early and oh by the way
push your H pawn within the first six or
seven moves castle early and play h4 and
play h4 h4 a try just just throw it in
there whatever whenever you want to
that's what we're seeing but that move
by Magnus Knight to g8 and now Fabi is
starting to show some moves that you
might wonder how did this position
happen 15 moves Ana you say reconstruct
this opening please and you'd be like
what eight six points h5 yeah that's
surprising I guess he was didn't want
five meters to park his Queen on aged
five for sure
I think the Queen coming to h5 would
have really been injurious first of all
because it just means you're not
castling short and the bishop being on
g5 means you're not castling long so h
h5 I felt was required
Magnus preparing to play f6 so that
actually his King weirdly enough isn't
heading in Queen sight weirdly is the
right term because you have to also
argue there's no security over on that
side of your pawn she'll completely
fractured we saw him have that same
problem in the game against first game
yesterday again
Aronian where he had that horrible pawn
structure on we decide you're laughing
yes because you're in this on structure
was so terrible and you know what
happened he traded queens he lost
material that he sacked in exchange and
then he proceeded to outplay LaVon after
Levon realize I can't get it going and
then Magnus won the game so who we Kings
to your list as well oh it's okay if
your Kings weak and your pawns to put
the proper reconstruction first magna
sacrifice one pond then Magnus
sacrificed a second pond and then he
sacrificed an exchange so he was an
exchange in two ponds down and that was
probably the moment when he had his best
position anyway and he actually went on
to win that game idea what I'll do with
the gate by the way that was a crazy
game but this one at least he's got
something going on for himself a lot
going on this final action you know I
mean a trial you've got one pawn she'll
then that's you know okay I mean black
starts to think well maybe I can turn
into an I don't have to just I don't
have to just sit back and defend my my
weak pawns on f6 or c5 or c6 but I can
turn there by the way sex has been
claimed what about rook takes f6
yeah actually Bobby just said none of
the above he's not interested in that
Essex pony he parked his knight on c4
yes that was a quick declining of pawns
well doubtlessly he was he saw this
possibility what he played the moot
Queen e1 earlier I'm still I like I like
what Maurice was saying just a second
why not is it is there something obvious
we're missing is it h4 I mean I don't
think so I think he's just intuition
told him that
you didn't want to open up extra lines
and you didn't want to think about it
for three minutes I think it was a
practical decision to say okay no grass
yes yes it wasn't the right decision at
least it was a fast one hey wasn't fast
Magnus said good and now you're not
getting a second chance Bishop f4 now
yeah do you want to play g3 and cause
some slight weakness in your position
especially it's like a play Bishop g5
you will not see this pawn twice and
Fabi said let's play b4 we're seeing
great brawl in this game the way this
game on these guys are classical
principles I was going to say I'm going
to say what I was gonna say they're just
throwing them out the window this is a
straight drop of play move play move
play move see what it looks like think
about classical principles later maybe
they're breaking all of them and playing
just wild chess so I was starting to
like blacks position by it here's the
thing what about my lady my queen on c7
how do I get her into the attack guys
because my attack is always be c5 he was
trying to solve that problem by playing
before and open up you know the p4
square for the Queen maybe a 5 if your
queen ever strays but so you play rook
g8 but how are you actually gonna thread
and stuff without the Queen in the game
good question but it's time anyway is it
gonna take some time
I don't think so I think the Queen's
coming to g7 and I think fab ease and a
lot of trouble where do you put your
knight though because then you're at 6
pawn hangs right which also works the g7
square wait what you think so what about
upon no I'm saying I'm checkmating you
down the G file Jen yes that's it so so
let's say I play rook g6 okay Rick team
a and Queen g7 well nightmares in Queen
g7 yeah you don't get to jump over the
night where you're gonna put the night
on f8 or something else
no I something's gonna resolve itself on
c5 right I see what you're saying okay
then you'll play nice
yeah well maybe though but maybe Fabi
will not take one
do not take on Sinn féin that would be
ridiculous yeah he's not gonna want to
give you that take that's that's crazy
he's play Knight to f3 what what I'm
gonna see against your threat yes I'm
gonna play Queen e2 and rook g1 when you
get there so I'm getting there fast
first of all he played b4 did white
fabbi to get it blacks King right yep
now Queen e2 and before I don't see the
control when you get there when you get
there so I needed another move the
moment you threatened the first threat
I'm gonna put my rook on g1 and when you
make the second time look like we know
on e 2 so I needed to move a third piece
so those two were stable maybe a move
like rook to b1 or rook to do or to do
you want to look like doing doesn't
anything work to be 1 maybe would have
been my choice on the previous move not
this one that you got your 9
you got your rook on g4 because I moved
my night off of that square h2 so maybe
he should have that's the game position
Maurice no that's what I'm saying when
you when you add the position early he
played Knight f3 you're right now with
the knight on f3 that rook can go to g4
and he has taken on b4 himself wants to
draw the Queen away Friday so the Queen
I wanted to be on on e 2 is now gone but
maybe he thinks he's getting his own
play Queen takes b4 by Fabi and he's
gonna be able to play rook b1 rugby one
and maybe shift the Queen somewhere the
version of R is whispering in my ear
how about Bishop e3 talking like them
apples highly defensive move I'll put up
a book on b1 again okay and now I want
to think what what var really wants to
do is stick a knight on c5 and the night
kind of like an octopus like style
defends a lot of squares around blacks
King and Bishop e3 the shout out too far
so root be one and you're gonna do what
afterward by 95 okay I was actually
worried about this bond but I'm gonna
play roof chief for first okay so my if
I move my quick okay what if I threaten
it then Queen a3 let's play Oh Queen III
it's your bishop you can't put your
night there and now you're asking for
tactics e5 doesn't do anything
c5 you can first of all I could trade
Queens as well see with Queen ace I
don't want to trade Queens forget about
that all those f6 is hanging is an f6
hanging if I play c5 right now for
example and I take on f6 I might be
running into a tactic somewhere but I'm
eating your d8 I'm eating a five you're
hitting e4 we do have Bishop e3 on the
board right yes never you work a b1 and
this is where Magnus is starting to
think because Queen a3 queen a3 could be
a threat and c5 and the f6 pawn and
tactics are bubbling I think the last
couple of moves magnets kind of blinked
with Bishop e3 maybe it's the best move
but it's not consistent with what you
were talking about yeah as the energy
and in the play and as I'm speaking he
decided to play the move a5 shocking
that are being created I mean now if we
play Queen a3 like you suggested Maurice
Bishop c5 is a rejoinder right yeah
tempo because you hit you're attacking
the bishop the bishop gets this retreat
with tempo which I don't think a 5 by
the way even in a classical game nobody
but that would be like number or on my
list of I would Bishop b6 I would by the
way was sabe of twin so he sank his
into the position ready now Bishop f6
I'm telling you what would I say street
brawl this feels like a street brawl
right now they they're just like I'm
just throwing moves unexpected shots
dropping on the board you want to play
cohesive chassis as bringing the rook to
g4 double rooks put the Queen on the G
line everything nice let me put a lace
Bishop on e3 let me drop a pawn on e5 I
don't care Bobby says I'm gonna play b4
yes my pawn structure looks terrible now
I don't have a single good pawn on the
board but you know what we're playing
chess this is just incredible and again
Fabi with that big-time edge 549 to 142
4 minutes the last time he had this
advantage he played it slow and came
letting Magnus come back don't worry
about it now just play intuitively he's
played Queen 87 not sure I need to e DD
8 not sure it was the best move but he
just got to keep making moves the Queen
can get to f5 I think that was the point
of that move get the Queen f5 I don't
think he wants to take the H pawn queen
f5 check move and I love the way that
Bobby is just playing so quickly he's
got a four-minute edge on Magnus and
Queen tonight to c5 allowing Queen if I
would check but he does have Queen d7
thank goodness so Queen h5 is not a move
I want to play with your quick showing
up on h8 no that was not in the cards
Bishop g5 it's probably like winning
right away for black if he takes on h5
every coach he has are you mad like no
way he's taking that bond the bishops
already sitting on e3 stopping him from
going to the g1 square
you're not getting away from this pin
what about you yes you like that or is
that a pickle cookie has captured the f6
pawn he put Bishop takes on at 6 and the
Queen's are off the board what do we
have here I'm calling it quits I'm not
taking that bar on h5 that's for sure
we just seen a queen trait everybody
after Bishop takes
time we've got pawn but the thing is
you've got those doubled C pawns and so
right now it's all about the past F pawn
versus the pause pass upon which one is
faster which one's more powerful are we
talking about the strength of pawns this
is so chaotic
by the way magnets now down under a
minute Bobby with 518 magnets will have
to right the ship he's played Knight
back to d7 I think probably will be
happy to see a move like that on the
board just back your pieces up stay away
from the cookie jar
I want you on the other side this any
defenses pawn Bobby now should just find
it I think just retreat the bishop we
have a huge difference in time 5 minutes
to 1 minute
I mean I mean because it's pretty hard
after losing a game like the brilliant
game that Diane has played in game 3 not
to be a little bit intimidated and
slowed down so this is some really great
confidence and fortitude by Bobby 47
seconds for Magnus just saw the move
rook I'm the wrong one and the bishops
have come off not a hundred percent sure
I like that decision by fabbi but as
we're about to see for now I don't know
no wow okay that's a surprising move
okay what what's the intention after say
rookie four hmm what is that night doing
here rook f8 going after the pawn on f5
but it looks like you just conceded that
the g5 square again one of those
attacking moves that create weaknesses
as well you could play Knight to g5 you
can't quite away knight c6 is yet but in
the meantime what does black dude down
upon that looks like a move that shuts
down the initiative oh my god what his
next move should be as as black yeah I
mean I g5 perfectly legit move all right
I was thinking of the other way Knight
h4 to go to g6 to go after the heat on
Lanai g5 zoo and he
do something keep the edge you got 406
get into flow Fabi oh you might want to
think now but you're going to have to
get into flow because 358 is the edge
you want on magnets and you you're up
upon keep that one him to to feel the
pressure of the clock blunders do occur
when he gets under 30 seconds you could
do that but right now Fabi
you know deep thing if he doesn't move
by 3 minutes guys I'm going to be
screaming and I don't want okay he
played Knight back to e1 what's up with
that
in c5 you looking at d3 and FIFA hide my
feelings too as black I want to play
efore which will arrest the night so I'm
thinking night that's about to say I was
lady Knight f6 kick the rook back play
e4 and smother the night he went through
that night h6 yeah I mean Magnus
wouldn't with really no time 37 seconds
594 okay what if he goes go read this
was that word triangles done an eye on
the pawn on f6 but is he is he defending
enough Oh
Fabia's working five coming as well
working five he careful there's a back
rank mate I think Ruby six here good
no he played Knight takes f6 sorry we
expected work takes e5 and then after
work takes e5 Knight takes d5 d6 pawn is
tender no you can't play rook e5 rookie
five is so good no Jenna Nigeria for
you'll play rook takes e5 Knight which
is which is on the board at the moment
okay and there's a rook hanging on f1
this is a there's no time to play rook
c5 or work at a five because the work is
hanging on f1 so you have to play take
the rookie why do you play can't and
there's a meet thread so that stops
from taking anything nice defense by
Magnus why do you think why do you play
King G 1 instead of rook all the way
back team so there's a defensive his
rook was hanging oh my bad
ok thought corrected yes his rook was
hanging so rook back rook d8 and now
what's the edge for two three looks
it's a pawn it's an extra pawn for white
but it's a half pawn because of the
double pawns
rookie for stopping the intended rook d4
King g7 okay King c7 King c7 on board so
yeah g3 King G to get his King out of
this little fab he's better
yeah he's better g2 he's a pawn rook to
f5 is there anything to be said for
warming up the board with our King
don't let night if to check happen
though yes I don't trade nights trading
nights he might he might get some
activity with his rook that boring rook
and pawn ending guys like you might win
but I don't trust that and he played
night at four instead mm-hmm okay
I rather like that night on d3 for the
reasons that it did keep the black king
honest our kingdom six is this dropping
upon I mean the h5 palm was under threat
why can't he just take it rook f2 can be
met by Kang Ji Won nice nice working for
and you've got I mean very healthy he's
looking around for the trick may be
needed what about 85 Knight f2 because I
care for the worst rook rook age for the
worse and he's done it he's done it he's
now won a very important pawn Magnus is
this this and this is what I'm talking
about keep the edge on him on the clock
he can make mistakes when the pressure
is high he's got to stay with you he's
got only 25 seconds left now and the
Bobby up a clean pawn in what should be
a technically winning rook upon ending
Oh Magnus
now getting desperate he's looking for
some counter spiel over here but
anything like c3 probably even a three
deserves attention as well lay and he's
played it just keep that key keep the
king at bay and now move the rook and
play chief for g5 and beautiful yummy go
baby
when is this is his the only thing is a
rook landing on d2 or b2
but while bad G pawn is LT racing down
the board
there it goes rook trying to back up but
make him feel the pressure of this part
and there's the rook headed to the
square now can you start pushing g5
absolutely that just wins the game there
it is it's on the board but so what g6
and you're after you're pushing the pony
home you're winning Rhys King at 4 easy
win
easy win so that he close you can also
play rook e3 no doesn't Ricky 3 hey he's
resigned that's it I'll be with the
comeback let's come back and we are tied
up guys with a really mad just in time
for our clutch games amazing we're being
okay right now 2800 punching at each
other
incredible I was a little bit worried
about this game I thought that things
were going wrong Lee for Faby just about
these parts right here I thought that
Magnus was gonna play rook g4 rook g8
that he Magnus was going to crash
through on the Kings side but Magnus
kind of got distracted he this White
Queen did some funky things range move
and somehow you know what can I say
fabbi came out on top of my predictions
looking good
remarkable practical play by the top
american player the number two player in
the world who does that against magnus
man
used to people getting to the same time
as him because they're like welcome back
is thinking I probably should think
lobby said not so much I'll keep my
Foreman at edge and swindle you in the
end and that's just what he did and now
this for is to to remembers and think
you're about to get higher two K instant
win if you win a game and two points for
the winner remember I said that I think
Magnus cuz I knew that if they got down
to twenty seconds each Magnus was gonna
win those games I love that Bobby seems
to be channeling that same pot I'm not
gonna let that happen
no no not the way for him to win this
match don't get 20 seconds verse twenty
second force the guys time situation as
well he may be magnus carlsen but when
the clock is ticking down you feel that
pressure and he played that move I think
was rookie at five allowing Knight takes
H five winning upon a crucial pawn in
the position and that rook upon ending
was winning this is what Bobby has to do
any edge you get it stops being the
objectivity on the board and actually
about the clock combined with the
position on the board and you've got to
keep that pace even great champions make
mistakes when the time is ticking down
yeah that's a remarkable oversight what
you mentioned Elise allowing that night
h5 because night afore you know just
have that concrete threat and you know
Magnus with very little time on his
clock
overlooked that the knight takes on h5
follow player takes g4 so actually play
King d6 not work at fine
you know ready play so night afore with
the threat and he missed it folks we're
gonna take a quick break and we'll be
back for those clutch games don't go
anywhere
[Music]
the surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience can you hear it it's
the sound of hope and health and
strength it's the sound of compassion of
open doors where people and machines are
in tune and miracles occur
it's a sound of personalized health care
and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear when you really listen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
college chess I'm Jennifer jihadi
here with Piazza Maurice and we've got a
tide Mac and you're going into clutch
this is what we do it for absolutely
Jenna is I mean we could have hoped for
a better more exciting match number one
versus number two in the world and they
both got a measure of one another as
they prepare for Game five the clutch
game worth two points in the match
there you see it as well as a little
bonus money of $2,000 but those clutch
points have been so vital throughout all
of the matches as they're important for
the tie breaks as well Maurice if you
could explain that to our audience yes
because well they're tied at the end of
regulation all that is they play the 12
games the first very first tie break is
watch points right and so if any games
you want to win I'll take the clutch
games you can win as many of those
single games as you want I'll just take
all the clutch games so that when we're
tied at the end arbiter says excuse me
that those clutch points count more than
all the other games so they know the
importance of these two and given how
equal they are in ability so far we've
seen it four games deadlocked
man those clutch games are going to loom
large and very important by the way one
thing you don't want to do is get that
deficit to be too great so that you feel
like you have a long uphill climb on the
next day I don't this kind of a very
close match oh I don't remember any
games any matches tied 2-2 do you I mean
I always remember people having a lead
by now some guys Magma's playing
everything he played see for the English
you play d4 and a London now he's
playing efore to be met by Bobby's
vaunted Petrov or Russian defense and
look at them go they don't even both
players at 10 minutes of 40 seconds
my goodness for each other they know
each other well and Magnus knows exactly
what Fabi likes to play so no surprise
here that he's prepared this one for a
world championship match played a grand
chest tour you name it he knows Fabi
he's gonna play this sooner or later and
he had to be ready for it so they're
playing very quickly at the moment we
see opposite side castling which usually
features dynamic play for those of you
who aren't used to this type of opening
one of the ideas is that White has this
fractured pawns on the Queen side but he
actually likes that because it makes its
King Soopers hey it's it's four in the
shield instead of three it also opens up
that D file so that's why white plays
this position on the other hand there
always is a possibility for a lot of
pieces to come off in the chopping block
so it has some drawers potentials but
let's see which way it goes yeah that
opening file definitely allows for some
drawer but Magnus first tank why usually
gets a little something and then Magnus
after deep thought came up with the deep
a3 I think it was Alejandro Alejandro
Maris was in our studio and talking
about his preparation that he did with
Fabiano for the World Championship match
and he gave us some real insights too
when you want to play III king b2 is
white or when you want to play a3 and
king b1 and the subtleties were
fantastic and very very deep but anyway
Magnus was the first player who actually
paused both players had been at 10
minutes 40 seconds Magnus took an entire
one minute wait a three can we point out
that Bobby has the thematic Bishop takes
on f3 which you might perceive as a
threat until you look and you say that G
file just opened up and I gave him the
two bishops it's imbalanced I don't see
how I get to an endgame to show that my
superiority exists in terms of pawn
structure
I might get killed before her the
endgame shows up as tower issues to say
before the endgame the gods have placed
the middlegame and you have to be very
careful when you create double pawns I
know a lot of students here that double
pawns as a weakness double pawns yes
that's a weakness let's go for it yes
but when pawns double files open
remember that and you have to be very
careful and Bobby I said yo I don't want
any parts of that exchange and he has a
said gone for a more thematic exchange
Bishop to f5 looking to get rid of a
light square bishop Magnus quickly
pounced with Knight to d4 looking now at
that f 5 square as a tender square in in
blacks position not a lot of pieces will
will follow as yet will stream into the
position but he's gonna have to be
mindful of it does Black Knight a5 is
definitely a concrete threat he has
traded bishops and I've always
attributed that quote that particular
quote to Michael tall because at the end
tal was supposed to have said and before
the endgame the gods have placed the
middlegame
and I think those gods positions I've
never heard that quote from him but he's
and I think he's extending the the
Tarrasch quote we could check we can
check the K who that I think Tyrus came
first with the first part and and tall
added the the funny ending there as you
mentioned right never heard that one d5
why get a very heavyweight pitch you
know opening battle my wing of thought
that that was the move here that Knight
coming to f5 really is very frightening
I'm being told by far that in fact the
move 95 is a novelty so ok certainly
this has been on his board Bobby's home
prep board but maybe not recently
because you you know we know we know
when the opening is completely fresh you
just bullet to that
so I feel like this might be maybe in
its files from London okay let's say I
do something pretty normal natural I
defend my piece I go Queen g3 I am I
don't know if it's a threat but I am
looking at a possibility of Bishop h6
what's the natural follow-up for fabbi
you mean why didn't he put the knight on
d5 in the first place you kind of
assumed he was trying to trade off
pieces right all right but then I see
what you're saying that when you get
your Queen posted up into the g5 it's a
really nice Claire isn't it it does
support Knight d4 to f5 I mean I've
always hated when I'm castled and I've
got that pawn shield in front of my king
like black this I always hated it when
my opponents to put a knight on f5 and I
work hard to prevent that so along with
the line and just play rook takes me one
in that line rook takes me one Rick
takes you on rook e8 thinking that you
don't quite have time to play Knight f5
because I'm if you if you for instance
tape on e8 and play Knight a5 well guess
what I do I finally found a crack in
your your view on structure there I've
moved the knight on d5 was hanging you
were sacrificing a piece Chet in that
line because in 95 wasn't necessary you
just play Queen takes right right yes I
I'm bad that doesn't look like you were
sacking a piece your knight is hanging
on the d5 square and the move rook e8
says go right ahead snack on it if you
want to you're gonna get made it thanks
to your knight sitting on d4 so magnus
noticed this and played Bishop takes on
e7 now Knight takes on e7 stopping a
knight from appearing on f5 there's a
smidgen of an edge here for white but
black has zero weaknesses in his
position at the moment nothing called
nothing really clear to target this is
this is looking close to equal and why
is it that fabi's always up on the clock
what about
cookie for just with the ideas of maybe
swinging to age for if the conditions
are right but mostly just playing
working you want and trying to construct
some kind of Alekhine's gun
absolutely trading off work so fast
you're just gonna play ninety-six you
man
actually actually I do have D five that
you're gonna have to look at Magnus is
alpha 0 slash Leila it and played age
for Leila no it's like it's like one of
those hey it was like what are they let
things where you say what took you so
long to play h4 we thought he sure wants
to play within like the first ten knows
saw the age for move on the board and
the beauty of this move is if you play
Knight g6 think you have some security
on that square well thanks for the
invitation
h5 shows that and then anywhere your
night moves my Queen the White Queen
will shift to some good-looking square
g3 looks nice or yeah there will be
options in that position so and that
night don't have on this before I could
literally invited his opponent to play
h5 anyway with this move Knight g6 we
were saying this is not a great move and
Fabia's put the knight on g6 anyway and
is there a way I'm trying to figure out
a way that I can like time it so I
attack your knight on d4 and you can't
play Queen g3 cuz of 92 but it doesn't
seem like the timing is working like 96
just play h5 right and I don't think I
have I don't think I have time to play
Knight f4 so I mean me Knight F word
don't you just have 23 or Queen actors
Knight a5 Queen f3 sorry yeah we don't
worry about 5 on the board I was
complaining about this move because I
thought Queen g3 would get the job done
it seems he has a plan maybe Queen g4
would be a move is that it is that a
smart is it might be four key five
there's a live Queen 63 worked ACH hack
right so you don't you don't have oh
thank you right all right I don't have
Queen g4 so
Queen g3 threatens eight-six do you have
to play eight-six yourself okay that
that might be that might be possible
Queen g3 play eight-six and say what is
your next move looking to double Queen
g3 played and again fabi's up two and a
half minutes on the clock
every single game well I think it's
through at least three games we have
said Fabi up big on the clock game why
David reads the was the most that they
had equal time but every other game
you're right it seems to me like fabbi
is the one who's really keeping an
incredible pace 95 rookie 4 on the board
now of course looking to get his rook is
rooks doubled on the e line although I'm
not really sure the force of that
because it looks like it will just be
chopping blocks oh there's a night at
five at the end but wait if the knight
moves there's let's say Knight c4 or
knight c6 even Abby is really thinking
this one over because for example if you
move Knight c4 we go rook g4 and let's
say you defended this you have to look
at the consequences of a move like
Knight a5 these types of sacrifices can
be dangerous probably not not probably
not now you're just leading with the one
the two pieces but he doesn't have
ninety six ninety four looks dangerous
like I'm falling into a tactic of some
kind I see six looks like it makes more
sense and it's on the board ninety six
and now it doesn't look as though Magnus
is going well this was what I was
worried about I was saying double rooks
and then trade everything off I still
don't have night at five cause a Queen
e1 mate look at that it still doesn't
work
oh no but I can play nine to five first
that's it
this one is mate but if you try to do it
if you try to do it like this the other
way he's played rugby for immediately
but yes if you
if you might you know mind if you trade
here and rook e8 now night at five and
you're getting toasted because you can't
touch that night and mate is on g7 and
end of story
no geometry that shows the importance of
the night and breaking through straight
lines I love it and he did play after
the move Knight c6 rookie for likely he
thought that rookie Wan would be bet by
Knight takes T for just a lie tray and
looks even that's even for short
ok so I have six is four is don't play
at five because I take Knight takes F
Wow yeah why would you give up three
pawns when you can just play up six at
five is very forcing allowing Knight
takes at five rook takes and they work
takes c7 that's a lot to do well there's
a mate right on g7 and also a threat to
the B pond and the deep on so yeah no
clarified at five is mindless but what
else can he play except that six like
why are you sitting here
I know exactly I always wondered about
that you know my favorites maybe you
guys have similar feelings is I play
Queen takes Queen check there's only one
move in the position it's forced it's
legal
that's king recaptures Queen and I just
love it when my opponent stop there and
think there's no choice
rook G for strikes me is one of those
one of those moments f6 is forced Fabi
has dropped below Magnus's time thinking
about a move that you simply have to
play there's no v there's no g6 there's
f5 looks just bad the only thing you
could be thinking is that f6 Knight to
g9 to f5 no he's played nine takes d4
guys he did not stop rook takes g7 what
he's allowed work takes g7 Josh
what with the idea that I don't know
what the idea is maybe he thought f6
rook g6 was really good for white and
just didn't see what to do here now he
wants to play like look at Magnus though
he didn't budge
we're in trouble you not just my keys
out of your chair Vaughn said he did not
bother looking at Magnus on camera he
said the guy's got no towels Murray said
he cleaned them up at the poker Jeff on
Monday I heard the same thing about
Magnuson you her no I'm trying to get a
read of this guy I I really liked the
ABC Wide World of Sports was an old
sports program that really was my
favorite and every weekend I went to
watch it there was a clip it was really
famous from the 1972 or Spassky Bobby
Fischer match Bobby Fischer played
Bishop takes h2 and well magnet pardon
me fabbi just played a move that allows
rook takes g7 if I had did a Magna
secede out of it like what there was a
delayed reaction because he is now very
much up out of his chair who spends a
bit of time in a blitz situation your
time is about five minutes on the clock
and decides you know what I'm gonna let
you take my g7 pawn with check my
position and then take back your knight
casually Magnus is like way way way way
way talk about what the point is guys
rook g7 King h8 pawn takes d4 maybe rook
to e to just invading in the second rank
what trying to play like Queen a4 Queen
f5 like me just get a little bit of
activity just get a what you could just
play dev 6 the guy still would've hadn't
any activity whatsoever what's the
difference
I'm trying to he was thinking as whoa
okay that's a cool move but is it a good
one if I take on g6 and we just all
start taking pawns
there's a lot of ripping and tearing
natural why did she just back the rook
up why I don't know I thought queen g6
was a visual yeah second game in a
second game in a row right like well
like yesterday that was a gorgeous queen
g6 twice yeah so it's like it's on your
mind I'd say this move was such a
shocker that Magnus might be Joe cool
but right now he has spent almost three
minutes no way
inspecting this night AC has not moved
he has finally decided to take Bobby
just moved and Fabia as with this one
shocker of a move Knight takes d4 that's
gonna be memorable as well for this
match depending on what happens here no
matter what happens how did Fabi
actually resist f6 and decide I'm going
to take on f6 we have some ballers
playing chess right now amazing and now
Magnus at 145 you know this is seriously
this is an amazing conception remarkable
conception by Fabiana just to give away
what to our eyes is a critical pawn
shielding his King and it's like the
worst feeling in the world
if Abby loses the game and it's happened
to me I came up with a really great
conception that simply didn't work and I
walk into the media center and the first
thing that the jerk chess journalist
asked is why didn't you play f6 okay so
he did play Queen f5 looking to play
Rory to threatening some nasty stuff
after he was played by magnets now what
does that do about the idea of rookie -
it could I think it controls the e1
square so that after rookie - I can play
the move rook d2 and you don't have to
check pulling me back
right now I don't have work eh because
then you do work takes you to work tasty
too and guess who mates first all you
need right but but this queen of five
with the rookie - idea is so interesting
because he can take on age five when he
wants to he could put a rook on e - now
trade off rooks and possibly take on age
five or even spend time playing like
rook e8 because the rook on g7 is like
it's hand is in the cookie jar
I remember that famous game Geller erver
from Zurich 1953 where where Geller goes
after every puts his vicious attack in
the nimzo-indian eight seven the rook is
on the G line and erver plays rook to a
h8 and it's a stunner it's like what you
use you drag the guy in even more into
your position and now the Queen goes off
side and then he just attacks him on the
other side when you thought White was
attacking and certainly was black who
flipped the script not it was a saving
line for white but it was such a complex
position that he missed it and it's just
a beautiful win sometimes you go in
there and then you can't get back out
properly you know you it's like you
stick your foot in the door and then the
door closes on you like wait a minute
can I get back out please it's one of
those and Magnus has brought his work
and this is exactly what's happened oh
no that was your analysis excuse me
rookie - wrote the D - he could he could
trade rooks and he's gonna get a pawn
back at least we're tasty 1362 Queen
takes 85 right it really is remarkable
and then suppose I bring my work back to
G for write like that yeah oh that's
that's actually dangerous I think Bobby
is probably noticing that he's not
taking upon so easily because of rook to
G for you might have read nothing alone
so you want to play that move rook e8
just to kick things off get trade trade
pieces and play rook e8 but what do you
do about rook g4 he's traded even in
that position after rikiei
we were in the line and that edge on the
clock is important he is up to 44 to 109
yes got to try to keep that
edge play quickly Magnus no longer has
any mating threats with any worries
there and if Magnus does bring his rook
back which he has done now doesn't
father you have a queen a5 check as well
there's the only taking on a private
suicide but Queen Queen e6 allows rookie
4 but check and where do you put your
king you have to put it on d1 either way
I referenced between Mac server and F
and Yeller and I questioned my attack I
had the pleasure of showing that game to
the Lindenwood chess team and it always
is amazing to me when you know like all
of these top young guns you know like
they've got their engines they've got
but they have no chess history they
didn't know anything about that game so
I could show it to them and they were
like oh they're in awe Queen a fight
check by the way we're in a fight at
King g1 want and now The Roommate
problem if you've done a c1 and now what
about Queen coming to be five or a six
running Queen e2 check and monitor and
Queen asked one check mm-hmm b5 is
definitely better hitting the b-pawn
instead of a six you get two and the H
pawn is still hanging so rookie four by
Magnus really quickly yeah these are
hanging and now if we play okay trade
rooks and pick your pawn he can take on
h5 with check at the end of rotation or
he could take on b2 as well
black blacks position is fine so we
could even play queen f1 working one
takes and then take on g2 you've got so
many options here right absolutely
that's another option he's take he shows
him to take on e4 and he's taking on b2
and this position is perfectly fine for
black that was amazing
that was gorgeous defense by black and
the fact is the only weakness he has now
actually is the pawn on eight six which
if he just defends it like he has we see
e5 on the board white has weaknesses as
well
guys that was amazing it wasn't
reception allowing work takes g7 check
never seen anything like it but here we
are now we're in a 1-minute game pretty
close to a head under one minute and
we're Fabi keep that edge yeah that's
exactly you do want to do that but will
he wear this Queen jak3 check is he
hanging the d6 pawn
no because h5 is saying we can get that
one as well so now he's been thinking
for some time though trying to figure
out the precise square for his King as
he's down to 110 this this is where you
got to make the last investment of time
and he's finally played King eight says
it looks like it could be potentially
perpetually it's just a little it feels
like maybe black will have some perps on
the light squares or even white could
like attack f7 like with Queen f4 and
then you have to go back to g7 etc I
went after Queen f4 there was there was
a queen trade possible as well there was
a queen trade possible Queen d3 check
that ending looks bad but the black King
would be stuck in the position but this
ending looks bad as the king could
actually gallop around and the pawn
structure will be healthier so he had to
just make sure that that was winning for
him you know it's a radical alteration
of the position and that's why thinking
he said but now Queen f3 and guess who's
down on time 30 something like it's no
longer in precise analysis folks we are
now in okay Queen g4 played and that
would have been the same answer I mean
f4 because you don't want to play King
g7 and allow Queen f6 Jack after breezy
for creamy 4 check played by Magnus
followed by a quick King g7 and they're
both 141 seconds exactly yep Magnus now
slipping under with 36 he's taking on d6
we expect to recapture on the d6 square
Fabi should be playing quickly now he
does get his bonus 5 seconds B sevens
hanging but d4 is hanging and King to d2
well in in a one-minute battle online
battle where you're playing with
computers
I have to say I've seen Magnus play a
remarkable number of matches on chess
calm even against Hikaru and at one
minute chess Magnus is amazingly good
like wow this is my god this is a
five-second bonus so it's not a bonus
that does give 20 seconds to 30 seconds
but fabi's hitting two pawns right now
the one in h5 directly and also Queen a5
check twenty seconds left for Magnus
seconds 5-3 acumen down to six seconds I
got his five second bonus Wow
that moves does cover both those threats
that you mentioned Murray said the
defense the pawn on h5 that done it did
stop Queen a5 check takes a three Queen
g5 check King c3 on the board Magnus is
playing a little bit more active in this
Queen upon ending the Queen a5 check and
your King has to go backwards this is a
drawer d5 okay he said no we're gonna
play chess g4 weakening his pawn on g4
and BC it's very solid
Magnus at 11 me too it was necessary to
keep the h5 pawn guarded and now look at
them okay now they're feeling the heat
of the clock both players are playing
very very quickly some very difficult
decisions - we just saw a check by the
way eyeballing a potential for Queen a6
and Magnus is play twice with a queen if
you take you play Queen a6 check and and
he got it he did factor oh sure
why did he do this that was terrible
that was a very bad decision made under
the duress of the clock and the problem
is when he takes on g4 he might lose d5
he's got 7 seconds 6 seconds he's
ticking it was a clutch game
we have sex and the problem is he can't
take on g4 because d5 is hanging so now
he's in big trouble and c4 by Magnus
you cannot capture that because I was a
ray and a winning ending Fabi in big
trouble four seconds three and he took
on g4 and gave Magnus two connected
passers he has won oh my goodness this
clock situation terrible for him
Magnus now just has to deal with this F
pawn is C pawn is actually faster it's
just about whether or not he can shield
his King but it looks like he will be
able to eke hwal in space at the moment
Queen d5 checky will be able to play c6
at some point and that pawn at least the
c8 square is guarded by the black Queen
black omens but watch out for
cross-checks Maryse it could all be over
if we get a pawn to d7 with a check we D
68 is coming with check and he has to
reason look at Magnus his face and he's
disgusted as favi as he saw that the
Queen was coming with a check giving him
no chance in the endgame and Magnus wins
a clutch game you're a brilliant
conception from Fabi I mean it's hard to
forget about that allowing her kicks g7
check but in the end of the day
scoreboard
Magnus got a ton and what's it about
what did we say not getting 20 seconds
first 20 not your friend time is your
enemy you cannot get under 30 seconds
mistakes will creep into your play so
keep getting to flow and keep that edge
the players who can do that play quick
moves the carbon arc of mores of the
world the Magnus Carlsen of the world
they with a minute left it's just like
please please please you ever seen you
know Keanu Reeves and the matrix when at
the end he realizes bullets don't bother
him anymore
and and mr. Smith I think his his name
is yes it comes Adam and the guys
punching as fast as possible he's like
please this is nothing that's how bullet
players handle it like
I don't care how fast it gets I'm just
gonna find the next move next one next
one next move and none of them are gonna
be major blunders that's what happened
to Fabi here in that bullet situation he
just couldn't keep up he just couldn't
keep up made that mistake and two points
gone
Magnus takes the lead again that's right
Magnus big victory there as he now has a
4-2 lead against Viviano who will try
now to hit back just like he did in Game
four with the white pieces can he do it
Ben I lose 16 score after such a great
play today would be demoralizing
well could you come back from that exact
score against Wesley so that is true I
don't want to don't want to try it twice
no don't don't do that especially get
magnet especially to clutch games
because that's a four yeah a clutch lead
point it mounted anywhere your tie
breaks are terrible in this case one of
your wins in the clutch game later would
not bring any solace to you if you ever
end in a tie even though it's for three
points so to not lose this next game
yeah so he played so well until he took
on a five like all the way down until he
took why would you take what any fine
there wasn't even a threat in the
position he takes that beat take on b6
wasn't even a threat Magnus gets kind of
threw the pawn up there you could have
moved your king I mean could we go back
to that moment in the game well just to
interrupt you
Maurice that after the move a four and
you're right a five you'd never take it
of course that was just Queen d2 let's
make a draw mm-hmm I mean that was like
the that shuts down everything there's
just nothing to discuss it's a green
perpetual after you played Queen takes
d5 but going to wait with Queen
defarge's Queen 25 Queen when you play
like we 85 or you just you would I I
don't think in any Blitzer bullet or
five-minute would you would you play BA
he just he just blanked out he missed
Queen a six chapters that was one more
maybe maybe he missed that after Queen
takes on ease
no it's check you got to go back and
then check and he's gonna take 185 I
don't know it time pressure time
pressure time pressure
it's pure and simple he might have
thought he had queen g4 right now
actually that's what he played and a lot
good night thank you play King g7 yeah
all he play King G something first and
then he took om nc4 happen oh my
goodness that that was bad news I was
young he died
well that that clock at the ticking
clock as you say Maurice it makes fools
of his all I didn't say it I think
Alekhine said it really yep I think so I
thought I was the one who made that
statement that's how I attributed it to
you I'm pretty sure tower said the first
quote about Irish said everything time
time pressure makes fools of us all but
you know talk to Cowart also said
everything okay we could you know
attribute it to all the old the older
this is the way back we're going back to
the 1910s and 1920s the classics we grew
up on and yeah you you've got a we got a
respect I'm and I set the stage for his
Jen well here we have it 4.4 magnus
carlsen Fabiano with two and that's
because magnets one that clutch game as
we've now had three decisive results in
a row after two draws that were well
played and not the most exciting games
of clutch shots we've actually had three
thrillers in a row who the fourth one
keep up the thread we hope so for a fab
you say because he'll be want you'll be
seeking revenge and a tight match in
this second clutch game and the last
game of today that's right and actually
he does win this game it would be a rare
case in which we would actually have no
tie break advantage going into the day
to that yet in class yes exactly I can't
recall in the quarterfinals there in the
seventh
finals that both players went to bed
with an equal score yeah it's usually
been one person one o'clock game and
somebody and then there was a drawl as
well so this is this will be really
interesting if I he does come back but
it's a tall order as you know he has to
win the game right I mean absolutely
last time he last time it was a Russell
Nemo right yeah and we saw that we saw
that HIV or AIDS I we said alpha zero
Lila chess play will we see more of that
because it was like h4 h5 9h to mind
there it is there it is I'll tell you
this is again we said alpha 0 and lela
lela influencing the play of today's
grandmasters 97-98 yes would you is that
in your winning chess strategies no well
before tonight mousse Maurice you're
always talking about how backward night
moves are hard to see and here one
backward night move deserves another 98
night h2 but the Knights aren't gonna
come back night at six F for Bishop e7
Knight c3 all on the board a knight went
to c3 really a natural square don't
worry it's going to go back to be one
and then it's gonna go to d2 later
now just makes sense
maybe 1984 b3 maybe two that's the other
option that that's hitting the C pawn
with the idea of going to c4 I see
that's deep that's real now now we're
really talking commentary there boy wow
that makes oh I'm sure it Irish didn't
say any of that
isn't that what Irish knight on the rim
is not far from being dim is
I thought it was more simple than that
night on the RHIB is dim yes maybe
that's what I heard about that feels
like an old-fashioned insult I don't
think people call each other dim anymore
right maybe that was more popular and a
way back when no no they have more
choice words yeah yeah but okay d6 and
now I find this position to be easier to
play for white blacks got the two
bishops but it just it requires a more
delicate hand whereas for Wyatt I feel
like my moves come a little bit more
obviously you know Queen f3 8 6 8 6 was
Bobby's choice by the way he just he
just got on with it let's let's do it h6
dynamize the knight so in case of g6 I
guess something similar to the previous
outing of this you could play for Bishop
g5 yeah sir didn't this age 6 move open
up a G file the first time you showed
that Magnus could have put his rooks on
that G file and take advantage what
earlier the previous game the bishop was
on f8 so h6 had I've had it I want to
say more ZipZap disaster it I don't know
you could take it you can take make it
win exact when you like I've even went
back whenever you like but the G file is
open that is true I need to take it and
probably played f5 shutting down this
bishop so that even if you do possess
the G file with the move rook e8 you're
not following it with Bishop h3 and
Fabio saying okay I'm gonna take back my
pawn with Bishop takes h6 and I got a
wedgie field of battle though is
interesting because the G file looks
like some place that black can can
dominate he's just put in here and he's
put his rook lane to hate I mean you'd
say you could have the pawn then I'm
gonna move my bishop out the way and you
have that wedgie situation where to put
the Bishop d7 looks like it'll be buried
for a while but a6 looks like as soon as
I spoke C
for appears on the board by Magnus looks
like he's planning to get some more
action on the other side a Queen b6 idea
and intensively it also go to a6 and get
some play on d3 or the c-4 pot possibly
yes
Bishop a6 I'm more worried about this
Queen coming to be - Queen b6 Czech
Queen takes b2 so if I take it would be
great if I could just get in these
consolidating moves b3 Queen d3 then I'm
a really happy camper the problem is is
I think you're just too fast doing a lot
winning my beep on I would be so I'm
worried about it yeah King h1 take it
really
Queen d3 Queen d3 so what you think
you're winning my queen saying you open
the file let's see what happens you're
ignoring me Bishop
I don't know I'm I'm not one I'm not a
big fan of leaving my king in the center
I know that in today's chess you know
modern chess there are so many
variations of the Sicilian which you
both play where blacks King stays in the
center for ever and ever
95 in this position is certainly
something worth thinking about trading
Queens and trading no no got to take one
f6 first and then take so I'm gonna
fight for the B file with you I wouldn't
worry it wasn't my queen back after fic
for king h1 okay
besides notice it does allow takes Queen
take so I mean okay trading off that
double palm makes what do you mean is
your sense strategic sense the king has
nowhere to go who you just open up
file if you now put trade off these
pawns up with the rook I put a rook on
c1 at least I see a target no I mean I
I'm your king
you may not be losing or maybe even not
even worse but at least you gave me an
open file I'd be happy to at least I
couldn't open the file myself and I was
trying to figure out exactly how to open
the file on the Queen side on the pawns
on c5 I'm saying how does white open up
this position I got that move my knight
I got to play some c3 d4 business B I
get B 1 B 4 all right I'm trying to
figure it out you plays c4 and then take
it on d3 and I didn't have to do
anything I just had to move my King out
of the way so you could give me the C
file and hope that I could take potshots
at you I got a 95 threat potentially
coming so I don't know this is this is
sharp stuff and it looks like Magnus has
decided yeah I'm not sure I want to give
you that open file my cell is definitely
taking his time takings time is backless
father really desperately wants to win
this game and be tied that would just be
such a great heavyweight fight 2 draws
that Magnus hits him Bobby hits him back
Magnus hits him Bobby hits back we're
tied going into the clutch games
tomorrow
each clutch game would be worth $15,000
15 is ran per clutch game 30 grand shift
completely over actually they're
currently right and everything if you're
also talking about the swing with
theater 35,000 there could be $45,000 on
one game I'm wrong I'm wrong because
Magnus just won the last game so the
ready 2000 went into Magnus's pocket by
purchases that victory but wasn't it
decided by popular vote that if game 12
of this match ends in a draw the clutch
money goes to the commentators yeah you
know especially since as the
commentators who have that vote so that
sounds you can split it off with the
crew guys come on oh yes of course of
course we
[Laughter]
when you said that producer Tom said in
our ear that's incorrect and then we
know when you change that he was like
look at the fine print guys magnus
carlsen is number to play this Bishop a6
move both depending c4 but also placing
pressure on the b3 point which by the
way can be reinforced some time by Rick
g3 hmm I see
yes three instead but doesn't doesn't
why I have d4 now just to make your last
two move look silly this bad
strategically before looks looks
enticing the only thing I don't like
about before is that e4 is could get a
little tender what a sacrifice and
sicilian-style there so sprightly with
these excuse I'm so quickly these days
no no no it was gen gen was making the
suggestion that the problem with d3 d4
oh is the e4 square I see yeah and so
maybe you say I like your chill move
Queen b6 yeah is just you know putting
pressure on d4 and b2 and like yeah hmm
I mean my bishop on a6 is terrible but
it seems like everything else is good so
well I must say that versions kind of
you know he's warming to blacks position
he's suggesting the move castles long
well first White has to make a move oh
no it's a bishop a six-lane White Part B
3 and he's suggesting takes takes
castles long sorry I meant to include b3
I did man you're asking for it again 95
hey I'm saying I'm asking for it
sky-eye 95 you can take some time you
take the night and place c5 maybe and
slow me down go for night d5 but b3
takes takes on the board pressure which
I guess he took the deep on to limit
like yeah he did take the deep on to win
the my wife's choice
and what now var says castles defy
played by Magnus curls five okay so take
Sony takes any port is the threat
because the pawn on d3 is pin so suppose
we we get out of and get out of God
something like rook to f3 nope that's
not a 5e didn't so attractive but K and
if you take if you take back it's bad
news I mean just pause for a second
because you never want to see these
parts boy he delights the I've and
Castle queenside what we're seeing
conceptions today my goodness this move
d5 and castles Queen side well Jen when
we sat down today and we said number one
versus number two in the world we knew
we're in for something special we we
have been regale it's amazing yeah if
you get the sense you're not only
playing number one and number two in the
world but it feels like we're playing
number one and number two in this format
in history or two of the top players in
this format ever they're just playing so
well considering these are ten minute
games guys 1905 by the way was played
and now as wait how do we try to make
use of the fact that we've got all these
open files like I want to try to play
Queen f3 and thread in like Knight takes
d5 but the problem is it seems like yeah
maybe Queen f3 because then also if
Knight c3 I get to play rook c3
protect mighty bond while attacking the
pond on c6 I'm a dad be careful be
careful of dropping back to b7 with the
idea of c5 might wake you up late not
maybe not right now take on c3 and then
break the bishop back threatening c5 is
what is what I was saying that could
wake you up yeah that piece of that
should need to be defiled suddenly
what's about the two bishops right I
mean that's one of those strengths that
black had going from the very beginning
in this game no it's about the
LightSquared bishop Jim it doesn't
matter if you're the two bishops as long
as I can compete with your dark square
bishop that's a whole different thing
but look at the light square bishop that
I cannot compete with this is what about
okay Knight f3 now we would have to play
but let's see let's focus on the game
itself because after you play Queen f3
okay so it could be 93 work c3 Bishop e7
and this time dropped his time dropped
below Magnus's in that deep think your
time dropped below Magnus's so let's
really focus on that and this position
is chaotic Magnus played an amazing
conception his King is weak he's
trusting that that's not going to matter
as much there's another move - here guys
- right we could go we could go night
before with the idea excuse me with the
idea that c6 is defended so you're not
gonna get to play whip take c6 but more
importantly I mean of it crashing down
on against the d3 pawn boy looking move
either Bishop takes rook takes rook
takes will come with tempo Bishop takes
comes with tempo so some nice options I
want to say for Magnus for black in this
position and out for f6 and Queen f5
check though that's going to be in the
position at some point as well as a yeah
your nightmares away there's a there's
an f6 you know just Bishop a three on
the board Bishop a three
94 instantly change with just no
hesitation whatsoever I think that he
realized that he was in trouble and he
said no way am I gonna suffer
ruk situ was night before with tempo so
he said I'm not gonna suffer I'm gonna
give up next change the way Wesley so
did against him do you remember in that
in their match he see this position and
Magnus said now I'm taking the exchange
it's mine
you're know he's done it that's on the
board and and now maybe white wants to
play something like a Knight f6 move
looking at playing Knight takes if
Knight takes f6 work takes c6 so back in
the car my problem is with fabi's
position is and look at the Yassir went
immediately to point out your knight on
h2 belongs somewhere in the game your
knight yeah like c5 port might like to
see five if you teleport my knight to c5
I'll say okay good conversation but with
that I donate to your a piece down I'm
up in exchange and you're a piece down
your Bishop might show up in the game
but that night on h2 ad takes a while to
get it up that horseshoe and make it
work and I'm just not impressed by the
sacrifice at the moment now I mean I
hear you loud and clear about the
exchange sacked by fabbi but you know
let's face it that that the problem was
after Bishop a3 keeping the exchange
would have led to really initiative a
very nice and simple initiative for me
for Magnus whether you liked it or not
this is had to be done and from a
practical point of view and again I'll
just point out the times five minutes
for fabbi
two minutes for Magnus mmm-hmm Magnus
thinking things over
Magnus is stewing here because he sees
that this knight on c5 is actually more
than an annoyance it's shutting down the
bishop and it's giving white place so he
hasn't like followed up with you know
having won the exchange he hasn't
followed up instantly and it took him a
while and
something about night before he didn't
like but he came back to it and he's
played it well now 95 can be met by a
capture on d3 now I was gonna take with
the issue yeah
even taken with the night was playable
by the what about Knight f6 and a3 just
trying to you're deep on is hanging I
know you mean you just play work takes
d3 then at least I haven't well no
that's probably not good I was thinking
I might have 98 take two works for the
Queen Queen e4 is rook d4 no but 95 was
played by the way in the game instead of
Knight f6 Knight c5 hitting that Bishop
on a6 I don't know I don't know now you
can take on d3 with something well id3
doesn't work because of because of 96
and if Bishop d3 even there Thanks
okay Bishop d3 I was thinking played
Bishop d3 on the board and f6 that just
came I mean I knew that was possible
he's a bishop now what he's trying to
play 93 in Queen f5 check a snap on age
7 no yes it hasn't no I thought he had a
three as a threat okay here's the deal
Magnus is at 57 seconds and counting
Bobby wood for 14 Bobby needs to defend
this position be careful yeah he just
hung a knight queen g4 check with that
move Bishop g6 that's the kind of
mistake he's looking forward to somehow
happening so this is it Magnus said 39
seconds Bobby must really focus and see
if Magnus can play perfect chest from
here don't we play easy for because that
allows Queen afire Chuck and Bishop f4
yes 30 27 26 seconds Magnus ticking down
now on the clock as fabi's gonna count
on the clock being his friend he's like
bishop back to b5
and we're hearing it's a blunder it
looks like the bishop is enough is a
four playable so keep going for okay a
six you have night takes a six and six
hangs and CC well there's a tactic on d1
gen watch out oh yeah good point
okay of course play though a four has
been played and Magnus with 20 seconds
left it's not happy well what just
happened aggression and there's a deal
Bishop a6 what happens after that
because you cannot take on a6 and try to
win because of a rook d1 at the end
the diverting wine right and then Knight
f1 rook takes a flan yeah so Bobby now
with 338 - of 25 seconds this strikes me
is like this opportunity here suddenly
for this Knight is tethered to the
bishop and I'm thinking Queen check
night at 3 get that night back into the
game we got Bishop d2 and Knight takes
e5 is ideas oh my gosh 3 minutes 3 he's
got to make sure he whatever he does be
practical and move with over 2 minutes
on his clock whatever he does he's
looking now he knows that there are
ideas and he's trying to find the next
move whatever he does make sure he has 2
minutes left
do not let your time go lower because
magnets will catch up and you'll be in
deep trouble so just right now there's
something and he feels it put his knight
just brought his knight into the game
with 9 - g4 may not be the best move but
just stay in the game and K wait a
minute oh he could take on e5 and play
for Bishop gonna 4 remember you gave me
you gave a line where there was a rib t1
now that the knight is actually made
look for the king can we take and take
on c6 wait can you take Knight takes a 6
Knight takes e5 hello take take well no
take on e5 and threaten knight c6 I take
c6 has been played you can't touch the
reddit and he's done it he's back and he
threatening knight c6 and all these
pieces work the night that was on h2 is
now on e5 and Fabi is back and winning
the c6 will not be defended Magnus is
looking easy 7 but knight c6 check is
possible take the rook on d8 and your up
material is this an endgame you want
though yeah that's easy that's really
easy with this round what a turnaround
he can take on he could take on c6 take
on d8 he's got 2 minutes and 13 seconds
Magnus at 14 seconds we'll have to
defend this pawn down endgame I so don't
want to trade Queens and fabi's not
Bobby's thinking though what is he
thinking about here are you thinking
about taking with a rock pause for a
little for a little bit maybe [ __ ]
enough for he's thinking about
interpolating that move but then King e8
and knight c6 is no longer chat
okay he's 151 he's looking for a killer
blow that make forced his resignation he
sees the endgame but he doesn't want it
he does not want that endgame he sees it
very cleanly he sees he can win material
will he chance it the best thing though
is keep time on the clock whatever you
do look at him he's going into even a
deeper think right now I'm not liking
this he needs to just go just flow get
in flow Fabi take on c6 which is which
he's done and now he's going to look one
more time and he's decide to finally to
take so he is ahead in material which is
remarkable given where he was yeah see
you were mentioning rook e1 he's by
Queen e2 he doesn't want to trade Queens
right I don't mind that one rookie 7 I
was thinking you know like let's unleash
the power of the F pawn oh it might be 8
guys I love this for white
why does play this just right now he
just needs to find some flow moves he
cannot spend play Bishop f4 maybe well
maybe defend your be pawn do something
keep keep the game going Bishop f4 a
nice move if you take on b3 we've got it
we've got to check and if you go back
we've got to take
we've got a rook see check and takes and
that's an easy win Magnus is shaking his
head and he moves with only 5 seconds
left on his clock now at 10 seconds
after Mitchell before Queen 85 on the
board centralizing the Queen does he
have a knockout blow it doesn't seem
that it the knight is defending really
well but where's the point just just
find a natural move to be careful you
guys
oh you don't mind trading Queens here I
understand Rick c7 is a possibility the
b-pawn is also hanging Fabi you've got
50 seconds don't blow this on Khan time
now got to make a move the tensions
rising it's here if you win business but
he's got to make a move and he's looking
around and queen d3 no that's not gonna
happen so before make a move just go the
Queen can't leave d5 so oh maybe he's
worried about nicely 694 Knight he's
played rook seesaw which I thought was
96 94 I thought that was the most
natural that's good because you're
eyeballing this down to just five
seconds and now Bishop to e3 to Knight
takes f6 they take that six you're
allowing Brooke tj7 Jack King King be a
forest of course
22 seconds for Fabi he has not handled
as quickly Queen d1 is not a real
fortnight g4 though he's a problem he
has to fix his rook and he's played
rookie 7 very wise rook to d7 allowing a
trade Bishop f4 check hold on there's a
Bishop f4 check sighting isn't there
he's got 11 suck he's got less time than
Magnus he's got less time right now he's
traded rooks he's up to pawns this is
winning just keep going before this is
it he can handle this no threats no real
issues leave your pieces where they are
and start marching the ponies he's
simplified he is one part I'm sorry I'm
in the to pass pawns to kinnexa the
other side it doesn't look like to pause
this is two for three for seven nights
of these six need magnets I think I
think we're getting a delay or something
because I swear back there is a delay
there is definitely a delay and is
therefore pen seconds here for petit has
to worry about because there and now
Queen d6 offering a trade of Queens
I'm not issues like the best gift he
could have given five it could have
given Magnus is this end game still hmm
I'm not sure why didn't Magnus play
Knight b6 and provoke the pawn to a
light square now we've got FIFA b5 check
King here's a tempo oh oh five on the
board nine she just play he's my baby
he's got it he's got the perfect
blockade how why you're stuck your scarf
King can come in win your queen size
King is come your engine to start
marching on the board just don't lose
the Jeep on ya you're gonna lose the
Jeep on and I'm gonna sacrifice my
knight and put my king on a eight oh how
do I win your pawn oh boy how do I win
your pawns that's the problem I think
it's a draw you're sure how do you get
my pawn bishop like drop what if he
keeps everybody drop the bishop you drop
the bishop back why is why are you
winning the pawn okay let's say he puts
King a six I wait for your king to to
march here to h4 and I go Knight f4 and
92 King age four has been played by the
way no threat yeah
King a6 g3 on the board 92 I'm not
giving you this pawn you can forget that
Oh Bishop d6 that's it Bishop d6 guard
the pawn what do you do now what do you
do not the bishops doing oh man why bish
is better than nights because of this is
it guarding everybody can he take now is
there a king c6 he has to worry about no
cuz he can just drop his Bishop back
he's won that pawn he's gonna win the F
pawn Bobby's gonna do it just I'm taking
g5 here
the last trick the last trick just play
king g6 and he should be okay
wait what 94 94 anyway right and he hits
the bishop
it's the pawn oh but he gets it you
can't take the beep on April 6 part the
a pawn will run she's done it he has
done it guys victory amazing win win win
we've had to come back snow from Fabiano
magnitude Psalm and Bobby hits back and
now we are exactly tied up in both
points and tiebreaks going into day 2
what you want this is what you want
we are heading as commentators we will
as fans you want to see something close
and these guys are giving us a show and
that so much reminds me of the London
match right yeah right yeah just trading
blows every game yeah you're right
Kraven win win win if only four wins in
a row they traded blows they're tied
exactly it will all come down to
tomorrow with neither side having an
edge remarkable chess going on
it's amazing and we have Fabi on the
line Fabiana Caruana
who had to bounce back twice the time
this match Bobby we are on the edges of
our seats tell us about these two
comebacks two great players trading
blows hey can you hear me yes we can you
hear me okay just want to make sure yes
yeah remarkable so very intense today
yeah I mean yeah it got it started out a
kind of boring and then it got okay I
guess the first game wasn't boring I was
just lucky to survive that but then it
started to get extremely crazy yeah with
especially these I mean these two
Sicilian games were incredibly stressful
and and also the Petroff game which I
lost was I mean I felt like I was kind
of slightly worse throughout the game
but it should always be a draw this
Queenan team but when once you get a
long time it does get kind of difficult
because white always has a safety net
and black always has to to be carefully
to move and okay this game I'm sure I
was lost at some point I mean though the
last Club gave me me in Game six yeah
yeah I mean Magnus just got low on time
I assumed he was trying to find a good
way to kind of finish the job
yeah the opening didn't work out I mean
this is just a disaster
so I was at least happy that I found 94
I mean I thought at least this makes it
not so easy for black sacrificing the
exchange you mean
yeah at least here the onus is on him to
to find the accurate way to win f6 was
maybe good practically because it gives
him so many options but he got low on
time here and this is why it became
difficult for him
you found a 44 and that night and I
looked just lost in the wilderness and
then all of a sudden it came back to the
the center of town and turned into a
beast no I was I was probably just
honestly I was just playing on his time
trouble which wasn't I guess didn't lead
to very good quality but in this
position with twenty seconds it's really
hard to actually be accurate yeah here I
thought it was over but then he kept
resisting in his position I was look it
was so hard to win this position despite
it being so overwhelming but I guess I
never let it go at least I hope I didn't
technically you didn't there really
other moves that may have been quicker
but in the end you won so now it's all
square did you expect the match to go
like this what are your feelings for
tomorrow no I mean how can you expect I
don't know if I was expecting anything
but how can you expect so many decisive
games and and trading blows but overall
considering that I was never really in
the lead today and I I was sort of
playing catch-up it's it's very good to
be on equal footing with him now
I mean to lose a clutch game and then to
win a clutch game in return is I mean
especially if I have lost this I think
that match situation is hopeless
not only from like a four-point deficit
but also the Tigers are just basically
means I have to win my last two games
like for sure so so not to lose this
game especially to winners is really
huge for me all right indeed you've
certainly kept us on the edge of our
seats
thanks very much rest up and we'll see
you tomorrow thanks and we do have the
world champion Magnus Carlsen who is
standing by Magnus it's it's been a wild
ride today for we as commentators I'm
short for the fans how do you perceive
the day as a player pretty frustrating I
have to say especially considering
considering the last game but I think we
certainly we
certainly pulled well but it's yeah as I
said not not being now face
yes not something not something I'm
happy with obviously you know it's
unusual for us to see you in time
pressure would look like you you didn't
quite have your your flow I know you
like to talk about flow being very
important to you any any reason for that
you think well the positions were very
difficult to play I would say and I mean
if you follow the games from the from
the chess 24 events the invitational
tournament so I've been in time pressure
pressure quite a bit so it's it's
nothing it's nothing new at all for me
but now I obviously becomes becomes a
problem when when when you encounter
something that you haven't foreseen and
done you have no time to figure figure
it out and that's obviously what
happened in that in the last game I mean
I thought I was I thought I did
everything right I thought I was just
complete for winning then he goes up six
the move that I haven't seen at all and
all of a sudden I have no time to figure
out what to do in a position that's
absolutely they were irrational and and
very very difficult to to figure out so
yeah I mean I was just really really
really fresh frustrating but that's the
way it is sometimes I know you're a
confident man you said that you're
optimistic about this match how your
feelings right now I know you're
frustrated but about tomorrow what do
you what is he what do you need to do to
get back that mojo I'm playing better
most of the time
I felt like in the last game like he
didn't really he didn't really
understand the essence of the position
at all like and I mean I got a winning
position without any effort whatsoever
but I mean I got a I got a convert
obviously he's a strong cleric fights he
fights incredibly incredibly well but I
don't I mean obviously I would love to
play faster but if I'm going to play
faster man I would have to play I would
have to play you know a lot less
complicated chess but and I think that
would also be it was fun for for the
spectators I think I'm in decent shape
it's just incredibly frustrating to to
blow that glass cannon
well Magnus thanks for joining us indeed
get your rest to get your mind right we
look forward to seeing you play tomorrow
thank you guys that was just amazing
we've never seen this score yeah never
seen this score in clutch chess we had
the American version they played three
matches we've had look the four
quarterfinals the two semi-finals
that's nine is four and two and three up
that's nine matches and it's the first
time a day has ended with a 4-4 tie and
especially the way they did this was not
your boring draws guys now that it's all
tied up yes tomorrow are we gonna have
our first high break of coffee clutch
shots well we could it's possible
it's totally possible indeed we might
see that as well for the first time two
different players and we - again Maurice
how much of those games eleven and
twelve and clutch chess worth well those
are currently that what they were worth
of the beginning of the day $13,000 so
we have four regular games and then
we're gonna have the two clutch games
which will each were 13,000 if they do
what they did two
they'll take the money off the table
each pocket that and since coach points
will be dead even as well they will play
a two-game blitz tiebreak and if they're
tied that we will go to the Armageddon
game which by the way will be decided by
a flip of a coin so whoa these guys that
shows that show too something today that
was absolutely remarkable and just a
commentator and a fan I mean look at our
predictions is that even we we're all
happy with our pigs move it I mean it's
just absolutely incredible the way this
is gone
guys this is just this is what we want
to see in a finals it's true and it's a
clash of styles as it's Fabiano who has
this precision trying to blitz out the
opening and get a big time advantage
Magnus trying to outwit him at the end I
mean it's been an incredible day they're
so tightly matched guys this is gonna be
a thriller tomorrow don't miss it we're
gonna be back at the same time 150 on
st. Louis where we are seeing those
Chess Club is sponsoring news event so
big thank you to them and I'm so excited
yes I'm thankful for everybody who
joined us and spent your Saturday with
us please join us tomorrow same time
same place
absolutely thank you for joining us
everyone we'll see you tomorrow for the
exciting conclusion of our finals match
well the magnets are favi we'll find out
soon
[Music]
[Music]